from calorie counter potion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in the US and in India
this is food Wars
the smallest Pizza in the US is the
personal pan pizza and it is six inches
across in India our pizzas start at
personal size it's seven inches wide and
has four slices
the US also has a small pizza but only
with the gluten-free crust and it is
difficult 10 inches wide so depressing
looking
then we're on to the mediums a medium
pizza here in India is 10 inches and has
6 slices a U.S medium Pizza comes in at
12 inches wide this medium Pizza is
equal to the small pizza in the U.S
people in the U.S sometimes it's just
really hard not to stereotype you guys
next up in India we have
nothing because medium is our largest
size that's right we have only two sizes
personal or medium no large for us
because Pizza Hut is watching our weight
I guess
stereotype away my man because in the
U.S you know we got this large and it is
14 inches in diameter so America's
largest pizza is four inches wider than
India's largest that doesn't sound so
bad however if you calculate the surface
area of the two pizzas those few inches
make a big difference the India medium
has a surface area of 78.5 square inches
while the US large clocks in at
153.9 square inches to save you from
doing the math that's a 96 increase that
means the U.S large pizza is nearly
double our Indian medium what the heck
Pizza Hut the type of crust you get
doesn't affect the width of the pizza
but how does it affect the value we're
going to weigh a medium hand tossed
Slice versus a medium pan crust slice to
see which one gives you more pizza for
your money all right I'm gonna do the
same with our pan and San Francisco
style pizzas uh they're medium size all
right so medium hand tossed weighs 94
grams
Pan the thick boy
Whoa 104 grams that's a difference of
what was the first one
uh that's a difference of this many
grams this one is pan style and it
weighs 78 grams this slice
weighs 66 grams fairly lighter and I
think this is because when they make
this pizza they press it down into the
pan and that's the San Francisco style
this weighs more and therefore is more
because it's more bread you have the
cheese and the sauce you want the fun
stuff right I don't know
oh boy this is gonna be trouble
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at Pizza Hut India that you will
not find in the US and here are all the
Pizza Hut menu items from the US you
won't find in India let's start off with
the foundation of any pizza the crust
starting with the San Francisco
signature style to my understanding it's
basically a pan pizza but they press the
dough in with their hands so it's kind
of a hand tossed next up we have
something very special it's a Schezwan
pan pizza
oh my God yeah I really like this it's
spicy really um just to give you some
comparison the way chicken tikka masala
was invented in the UK but clearly
inspired by Indian Cuisine Schezwan
sauce was actually invented here in
Kolkata by the Chinese community that
settled down here but it's obviously
inspired by Chinese cuisine and now it's
become part of Indian Cuisine we have
accepted it Holi and we eat it all
across India very exciting to see it
integrated into the Pizza Hut menu and
it actually tastes very good on this
pizza next up they have a stuffed cheese
crust Max with two x's for emphasis you
can already see that this thing is
loaded with cheese next to the cheese
alongside it there's like a sort of
creamy sauce which Pizza Hut is calling
Peruvian creamy sauce
wool
oh my God yeah this is decadent food
next up we have a stuffed crust with veg
Kebab that's right if you don't know
what Kebab is it's basically meat that's
cooked in like a Tandoor if you don't
know what a Tandoor is please go watch
the older episodes of food was I've
explained it eight times a lot of people
like to leave the crust behind but I
feel like pizza is making sure all of
the pizza has eaten because even this
looks like a dish in itself at this
point
my God it's really young and the final
option the stuffed crust with a
non-vegetarian kebab
as you can see this is what looks to be
chicken chic
oh that's the best of a lot that was
amazing oh my God smashed it Pizza Hut
that might be the best pizza I've had on
poorva so far and I didn't even eat the
pizza apart we also have a variety of
crust options in the US starting down
here you saw it already here it is again
the hand tossed this to me is like
Classic this is the default you guys
don't have hand tossed moving on thin
and crispy I mean how much
they can't charge the same amount for
this right I don't think they should
moving on over here the original stuffed
crust they put cheese in the crust can
you believe that
it is it is solidified doesn't stop me
from biting into it
yeah yeah yeah last
and let's be honest least gluten-free
crust look I don't know what's going on
gluten allergies and my apologies if you
have one but I'm look at this I'm just
like I'm sorry guys I mean is this that
much better I don't know how you can
enjoy this and for a limited time Pizza
in the U.S has Detroit style pizza let's
go let us go look at this are you
kidding me with this Detroit style pizza
what's Detroit style well they cook it
in a square pan that has like sides to
it it's like when you cook brownies in
every brownie is like a corner or end
piece it's like that for pizza so every
slice is gonna have the crispy crust on
the outside is thicker one of my
favorite pizza Styles I'm glad Pizza is
doing it generous with the pepperoni
guys I appreciate it
not the best Detroit pizza I've ever had
but it's pretty good I think they go
bread cheese topping sauce these are the
toppings we found under the categories
classic favorites and Delight very
arbitrary name but yeah let's jump into
it the first option is chicken sausage
smells really good a lot of onions I
love onions
it's pretty classic the next Pizza is
spiced paneer paneer if you don't know
is cottage cheese we make it all over
the place here in India and it's one of
our favorite ingredients we use it on
everything even pizzas
not very spicy but definitely it's got
like a Tangy twist to it next up we have
the veggie Feast it's got some herbed
onion capsicum and sweet corn
this is like such a wholesome chill
Pizza it's definitely a classic it's
something your mom would make at home
next up we have the veggie Tandoori
which I have already taken a bite of we
got this one with the Schezwan crust so
it's definitely spicier than the typical
pan pizza you'll get and I already
tasted it and I told you I loved it I
love the spice next up we have spiced
chicken
meatables it's a very straightforward
pizza but we got it with the cheese
burst filling next up we have the
chicken and corn Delight it already has
the word delight in the name so I'm
assuming it should be a delight but I'll
be the judge of that capsicum chicken
just strewn across and corn
it's got too much going on I would say
personally I would not order a pizza
like this next up to round it all off
this is the double chicken sausage pizza
am I wrong in saying that this just
looks like a boring version of the
normal chicken sausage pizza which has
onions and this feels a lot better we
have a pepperoni pizza that is made of
pork and that chicken and a pepperoni
lovers Pizza which one has more
pepperoni I can't tell the Supreme Pizza
it has pepperoni mushrooms green peppers
onions and that's it but if that's not
Supreme enough for you we have the super
supreme which now they've introduced
black olives meat lovers baby meat
lovers you got pepperoni you got bacon
you got sausage I bet there's something
else on there that I don't know another
meat I just it's beautiful this next
Pizza is the veggie lovers and I
absolutely hate it now you want veggies
go get a salad and put on pizza like
you're not fooling anyone right Backyard
barbecue chicken Yulie do you have
enough b-roll
I think it's barbecue chicken but I
think they use barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce genius genius
this is so good oh yeah a buffalo
chicken it looks like surprisingly good
Pizza does not have a straight Hawaiian
pizza on the menu the only thing they
have is Hawaiian chicken I see obviously
chicken I see a pineapple
I think I say ham yep I think Hawaiian
should just be pineapple and bacon if
you want to throw some chicken on that's
fine but if you have a strong opinion
either four against pineapple on Pizza
you're wrong it's a perfectly fine
topping I don't know why everyone gets
so worked up about it more pizzas and
these are all part of the Signature
Collection
um there are 11 pizzas in front of me
two
ah okay first off the country Feast um
it looks super Saucy it's all loaded
with vegetables there's mushrooms
capsicum onion sweet corn roasted
Peppers everything that you want on a
country uh themed Pizza all right next
up we have Tandoori paneer if you
remember in the previous categories we
had spiced paneer so all I'm looking for
is why is this different
oh my God
that's really yum next up is the veggie
lover it's basically got tomato onion
capsicum mushrooms and some red paprika
and hopefully a whole lot of flavor
it's underwhelming I'm gonna be honest
next up we have chicken tikka everybody
knows chicken
it's a bit too strong too Tangy and I
think they could have gone a thinner
layer of sauce next up we have the Malai
chicken tikka Malai is basically cream
so Malai kebabs they basically Grill the
chicken and they pour Malai on top we
have the chicken pepperoni double paneer
Supreme you like paneer you like Supreme
clothes well this has double of it minus
the clothes veggie Supreme everybody in
India has heard of this pizza this is a
painting I can genuinely see this on the
wall of an art gallery this capsicum
there's olives there's corn there's
onions there's corn again veg Kebab
surprise I'm curious to know what's
going to be surprising about this
surprise surprise it tastes Bland and
now on to our penultimate signature
Pizza this is the chicken tikka Supreme
woohoo
basically what I've done is they've
taken four different kinds of chicken
and they put it on a pizza and finally
in the line of signature pizzas we have
Triple Chicken Feast it has all of the
above ingredients and we've also gone
the extra mile and taken it with a
chicken stuffing in the crust overall
Pizza Hut has actually killed it I think
all the ingredients are tasted Super
Fresh all the meat has also tasted
really soft and Juicy and Delicious and
the sauce has been consistently yummed
throughout damn Pizza Hut
good job as mentioned before currently
have a Detroit style pizza at the U.S
Pizza Hut this is what it looks like two
slices of missing I skipped lunch and
breakfast to be honest for those of you
outside of the United States Detroit is
a city of Michigan they have their own
style of pizza I really enjoy it you can
also get it as a supreme Detroit style
and a meaty Deluxe Detroit style and I
didn't get them because it all looks
exactly like this one fun option on the
pizza at India menu is a new range of
momomia pizzas which are pan pizzas with
Momos baked into the crust now if you
don't know what Momos are they're
basically dumplings from Nepal and Tibet
they served all across India and they've
become huge favorites for everybody over
here they've also given a Schezwan sauce
to the side which is what you typically
eat with Momos
hmm
that ain't right I don't see how this is
working I can't think of a single
Italian who would put a pocket of
ravioli on top of a pizza and then bake
them together
and this is effectively what that is we
also have a range of flavor fun personal
pan pizzas that you can get with a host
of new flavors starting off with classic
corn next up we have the classic onion
and capsicum Tandoori mushroom and corn
so it looks similar to this but they use
Tandoori sauce and they've added
mushrooms next up we have the classic
paneer onion and capsicum then we have
the classic chicken sausage but personal
pan sized next we have the Italian
pepperoni and onion and just a reminder
that the pepperoni that they've used is
chicken pepperoni tandoori chicken tikka
and onion and the classic Loaded Chicken
Delight personally
I wouldn't order these pans I would get
the larger pizzas because they tasted
way better on top of set menu items we
can also customize our pizzas in unique
ways for example if you don't want
tomato sauce as your base you can sub it
out for creamy garlic parmesan barbecue
sauce remember from before buffalo sauce
or a no sauce option if you are a maniac
and if you want you can specify light
regular or extra sauce unfortunately we
can't change the sauces on our pizza
bases but we have a bunch of custom
toppings that you will not find in the
US like baby corn sweet corn herb
veggies spice paneer and veg kebab and
we also have exclusive toppings you
cannot get in India for instance we have
pepperoni which is pork Italian sausage
has pork bacon uh I believe it's pork
meatballs beef and pork ham pork and
then beef
and pork then the vegetables we got
white onion we got pineapple which is a
fruit and we have banana peppers which I
don't know if it's a fruit or a
vegetable or a pepper our peppers fruit
whenever we have the option of
customizations on food Wars we like to
combine all of our exclusive ingredients
to make an india-only pizza so this
pizza has a Schezwan base with baby corn
wedge Kebab spiced paneer and herbed
veggies it looks pretty gnarly I'm not
gonna lie but let's see how it is
[Music]
hmm I can see why Pizza Hut didn't put
this officially on their menu because
maybe the ingredients go don't go that
well together but hey this is an India
only Pizza Hut pizza and that means
something and of course we had to create
our own us only pizza so the thin crispy
base creamy garlic Parmesan sauce beef
bacon white onion and everyone's
favorite vegetable banana peppers
this looks like a cartoon Pizza wow
okay is that bad it's not great I
wouldn't get it yeah it tastes like
onion and bacon don't get this oh
Pizza Hut has a bunch of sides so let's
start off with the breads first off we
have cheese garlic bread then we have a
spicy Supreme cheese garlic bread it's
basically cheese melted on top of a
garlic bread baguette it's got some
green chili and some chopped onions it's
very delicious when it's hot Mexican
garlic bread sticks oregano sprinkled on
top some jalapenos some chopped olives
and onions it looks really delicious
creamy garlic bread sticks and finally
we have garlic bread sticks in a little
packet that says garlic breadsticks
the U.S Pizza Hut only offers regular
breadsticks and cheese sticks so in fact
the only actual exclusive side that we
have in the U.S is fries we have a bunch
of other sites including baked cheesy
Momo's wedge and baked cheesy Momos
non-ridge
that's a potent smell you know what
it's not half bad next up we have potato
poppers which are pretty much tater tots
we have the indie rock and roll veg and
the indie rock and roll non-veg this is
basically a roll but I like how the wrap
is kind of thin
no again it's quite good next up we have
the zesty paneer pocket and the zesty
chicken pocket uh these are pretty much
like pizza pockets there's some mint
Mayo some normal Mayo some cream cheese
chicken and jalapenos we have jalapeno
poppers I imagine they're just filled
with cheese and some jalapeno bits oh I
did not expect that consistency and that
brings us to an old classic chicken
wings spicy baked chicken wings so I
suppose they're a healthier alternative
Wing Street Wings yes both traditional
and boneless you can get them in the
following flavors lemon pepper oh let's
go lemon pepper
I usually don't like lemon pepper but
these are pretty good ooh honey barbecue
he's got these things are like
condensation uh oh the medium Buffalo oh
Cajun style
[Music]
eh just okay spicy garlic but naked
that's wings with nothing on it why
would you do that I don't know Buffalo
burning hot three Flames
um
this should be a medium oh wait
yeah okay
sweet chili am I sweating I feel like
I'm sweating
they're all just you know I mean I like
wings maybe my wing standards are too
high garlic parmesan oh
my God I mean it sounds like pasta sauce
it's really thick and it's got a lot of
flavor to it but
it's just like sitting in the sauce so
either you get a mouthful of sauce or
none and these come in portions of 6 12
18 or 36. and next up on the menu you
can also find a range of pastas starting
with the creamy mushroom
you know what if I have to listen to
this so will you all
just get get some of the boom make
[Music]
decent pasta for a fast food restaurant
they have a Cheesy Comfort veg pasta and
a Cheesy Comfort chicken pasta It's too
gooey we have the spice tomato twist veg
pasta and the spice tomato twist non-veg
pasta if you come to Pizza Hut to order
pasta
I hope we never cross paths nakio you
have no idea we absolutely love our
carbs in this country and as you can see
we have bowls and bowls of carbs that we
call Pasta you can get four exclusive
oven baked pastas add pot pasta Hut at
Pizza Hut
I'm not eating any of these they all
taste terrible all right the end you can
get a oven baked chicken alfredo don't
get this or if you don't like chicken
you can just get
cheesy Alfredo and then of course we
have the Italian Meats pasta which is
pepperoni and Italian sausage I mean oh
oh Italy oh Italy
I'm so sorry and lastly the oven baked
veggie pasta I mean this this is this is
a doorstop
I I can't stand the Pizza Hut pasta I
cannot stand it you see the sauces you
know what time it is
exhaust talk starting down here get
yourself blue cheese sauce then get
Ranch oh a garlic sauce we can have a
honey barbecue sauce a medium buffalo
sauce and a side of marinara just for a
dip in your breadsticks and also the
icing the Cinnabon icing for the
Cinnabons and there's a note that says I
really want to see Joe dipping some
pizza in the frosting and eat it
ah
give me this
oh
excellent at first I was like yuck but
this is kind of good and now on to dips
your dips
first off we have tomato ketchup
then we have a mayonnaise fun fact it's
veg mayonnaise doesn't have any egg
because a huge population of this
country is pure vegetarians which means
that they don't eat anything from an
animal
even egg then we have a cheese dip and
finally it's a Schezwan sauce and if so
they serve it with the Momos they serve
it with a bunch of other things
yeah we got this Rich you're not gonna
find in India that includes down here
the cinnamon sticks they're like
breadsticks only cinnamony
get your mind out of the gutter and
moving on we have here are the Cinnabon
mini cinnamon rolls this is the triple
chocolate brownie if I had to guess
two pounds what you got here the
ultimate chocolate chip cookie
right
this is like a frisbee
and for all you Sweetie Pies out there
with sweet tooths here are India's
exclusive desserts starting with a Choco
lava cake baby
[Music]
molten the chocolate cake in Domino's
much better next up you get a whole
range of ice cream some quality walls
one of India's biggest ice cream
manufacturers you can get a tiny tub of
chocolate Supreme sundae then you can
get a Cornetto a cone super delicious
and I really love the end of this
because it's just a block of chocolate
and I used to fight over this with my
friends then you get a magnum everybody
loves a magnum and finally you can even
get a family pack of ice cream
soda last exclusive are of course the
drinks both countries have Pepsi but the
pizza in the US you can also get Wild
Cherry Pepsi Orange Crush
Mountain Dew baby Sierra Mist which they
didn't have and Aquafina here in Pizza
Hut India our exclusive drink options
are Pepsi 7Up mirinda and Pepsi black
they also serve an iced tea at the
restaurant but they don't deliver it
unfortunately I would have gone for the
iced tea
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at Pizza
Hut's pricing particularly some clever
marketing tricks they're using to make
you believe you're getting more value
for money than you actually are in the
US a medium cheese pizza and the pan
crust will cost you
13.49 in India a medium Margarita Pizza
will cost you 319 rupees which is
currently 3.93 US dollars that means
over here you are paying 11.9 cents per
square inch of pizza while over here in
India you're just paying 4.4 cents per
square inch of pizza that makes the U.S
pizza 170 more expensive generally with
pizza the more you buy the cheaper cats
a US large has a surface area of
153.9 square engines and costs
15.49 that brings the cost per square
inch down to 10 cents making it 15
cheaper than the medium ladies and
gentlemen it's time for pizza pop quiz
which has the higher surface area why 1
medium pizza or two personal pizzas if
you said two personal pizzas
congratulations you're an idiot because
when it comes to calculating the surface
area of a circle small changes in
diameter can create huge differences in
surface area on the Pizza Hut India
website you can get a combo offer of two
personal pan pizzas for rupees 279
however a medium Pizza costs pretty much
the same but I guess if you want two
different flavors of pizza it makes
sense to go with the combo
and this medium cheese pan crust pizza
it is 1 940 calories 79 grams of total
fat 33 grams of saturated fat 224 grams
of carbs and the sodium oh boy
3480 milligrams a medium Margarita Pizza
in India will cost you 1 377 calories
total fat 40.29 grams of which saturates
are 14.7 grams carbohydrates 192 grams
and
2717 milligrams of sodium yikes now the
American stats look a lot worse but I do
want to point out that our medium is
much larger than India's so if you break
it down per square inch you'll see that
the US version does have more fat and
more saturated fat but India's Pizza
actually contains more calories carbs
and sodium but what about the most
calorific item on the Indian menu if you
really want to mess up your day you have
to order the medium wedge surprise Kebab
pizza with wedge Kebab stuffed crust a
whole one of these pizzas will contain
2673 calories that's
133.65 percent of your daily caloric
intake allowance oh my God okay the
calories are high but the sodium is even
higher that is 6 344 milligrams of
sodium in here which is 275 percent of
your daily recommended allowance what
about the most calorific Pizza in the US
well that would be a large pan crusted
meat lovers which this isn't so imagine
it bigger and thicker okay an entire one
of these contains a whopping
3570 calories it's 178 your daily
allowance and the sodium is even worse
than that of India's There's 7 150
milligrams of sodium in here that is
298 your daily recommended amount from
garlic on to portion sizes we wanted to
find out all the differences between
Dunkin Donuts in India and in the US
this is food Wars
[Music]
here in the US you can get your Donuts
in one six or a half dozen or twelve AKA
a dozen don't put that in there
here in India you can get your Donuts in
packs of one
three or six one U.S sticky glazed
donuts Indian glazed donut it weighs
49 grams 59 grams in the U.S we have
four sizes of hot coffee the small
the medium the large which Unfortunately
they forgot Duncan and the extra large
here in India our filter coffee comes in
one size this one if you're wondering
what filter coffee is it's one of the
most popular drinks here in India it's
made by taking a decoction of coffee
mixing it with sweetened milk and
typically when they're preparing it they
pour it from a huge height to create
this froth it's super delicious and it's
very strong it'll wake you right up in
the morning as for our other drinks they
come in two sizes either medium or large
this is an Americano let's wait to see
how much we got
I might have to go to the bathroom after
this
10.14 fluid ounces
but that's not enough for you Duncans in
the US also has a box of joe which
contains a hundred ounces of hot coffee
and
oh yeah
this should be the extra large in the US
we only have three iced coffee sizes the
small the medium and the large no extra
large but they did remember a large iced
coffee so thanks Duncans so the Duncan
India website says that they serve an
iced Americano but we asked three
Outlets here in Bengaluru and they said
no ice Americano we even asked them hey
can you put some ice in our Americano
they said no so if you really must have
an Americano that's iced from Dunkin
have to take it or nice and go there
so what what what's the large spot it's
supposed to be 32 I mean I think it's
yeah the cup says 32 supposed to be 32.
Julie zoom in on that and shame this
business
32.
this is everything that you'll find on
the menu at Dunkin Donuts India that you
will not find in the US here is
everything you can get in a U.S Dunkin
Donuts you can't get in India let's
start off with this one it is called
charcoal Villa and I think it's called
that because it's a little triangle of
chocolate which looks like those houses
we used to draw as kids
oh my God yum it's filled with my
favorite donut feeling ever which is
Bavarian cream choco almond
it's okay it's filled with the Bavarian
cream again
with the cream
unreal on to the next one this is called
a chocoholic it's got a piece of KitKat
sticking through it I want to see if
it's one kicker bar if they've taken two
and they've sandwiched them together
let's pull from this end yeah I was
right
if you're a chocoholic this is the one
for you the inside is also got
chocolatey filling in there
the chocolate is starting to hit me real
hard right now
this stuff is so sweet this is called
rainbow crunch
oh there's strawberry frosting on top so
this has a strawberry taste it's okay
it's a donut next up we have cookie
Delight it's called cookie Delight
because they've taken cookie powder and
smacked it on top this one's called
crispy crunch for people who have
Trypophobia this one is probably not for
you
God this ain't it the crispy stuff on
top is just not working again however
they do have the Bavarian cream inside
I feel like there's a hurricane inside
my body right now next up we have a
donut called
the Jenny my fellow Indians will
recognize that there are gems on top
this is one of the most nostalgic
chocolates here in India and I've eaten
them since I was a kid
super yum
you'd think a kid would like them but I
can't even imagine a kid version of
myself liking something that's so
overdosed with sweetness and chocolates
is it Jimmy yes two Gemmy also yes I'd
avoid so I thought this was all the
exclusive signatures but I've been told
that there are two more and let's start
off with this one it's called choco pop
it's got chocolate on top chocolate
sprinkles chocolate wavy lime things and
Spilled with chocolate it's very sweet
[Music]
whoa
all right and on to our last donut this
one is called the choco Berry bomb
actually quite nice it is definitely cut
the sweetness that I've experienced
there's like some Berry Jam inside which
is kind of tart and nice the top is milk
chocolate with shavings of white
chocolate yeah
it's a good donut I wouldn't order it
it's too much all of this I would not
order any of these they're too much
exclusive Donuts you get in the US you
can't get in India now we're filming
this the first week of October of course
the number one flavor you get this month
is pumpkin
yeah this tastes just like pumpkin pie
also you can get yourself a glazed
blueberry donut see look at that glaze
on top Blueberry dough on the inside
also delicious love that glazed
chocolate figured this was everywhere
right
so good ooh Boston cream the Ben Affleck
of donuts looks like a regular donut
doesn't it everyone in India but
the prize is cream on the inside
I know everyone likes Donuts I haven't
donut in a while but crap this is really
good one of my favorites I've cooked
with these double chocolate maybe my
favorite because it just did what they
had to do take a chocolate donut and put
that chocolate frosting I like right on
top of it
a double thread oh these are so good
I am in heaven
nice strawberry
frosting with sprinkles you know got
this this is like the Homer Simpson
donut right this is the the one that you
always see him eating oh the vanilla
cream
gotta say don't think we had this one
before
coming it's like Scarface over here I'm
just covered a lot a little much oh
God here's some powder right here
powdered donut India you don't know what
this is come on it's a donut number one
right
also in the US you can get a vanilla
frosted with sprinkles and a bear claw
which unfortunately did not have at the
time of shooting this hang on
munchkins guys ain't got munchkins what
we have a variety of Munchkin flavors
but this one specifically is the pumpkin
munchkin and
mmm
tastes just like pumpkin pie fantastic
hey guys we're now on to a different
category of donuts called the all-time
favorites I took a quick hospital visit
and I'm completely fine now I'm sorry
about the madness from the previous set
of donuts um I'm fine now I don't know
what came over me okay so we'll start
off with uh this specimen over here it's
called the cookie cartwheel adorable
name and yes it does look like a wheel I
like how they put the White Stripes
[Music]
yeah it's sweet next up on our list is a
donut that's not intimidating at all
it's only called death by chocolate
will this kill me probably not but will
this kill me from diabetes if I eat too
much absolutely and for that reason it's
a win in my book if you thought death by
chocolate was scary
this is alive by chocolate in terms of
visual differences I can already tell
this one has more of a cookie crumble on
top they're very similar as expected I
will say this one is feels more like it
lifts your spirits and you feel more
alive and this one will probably put you
to sleep in a coma so death and Alive it
makes sense
[Music]
whoa on to the next one we have
something called very very
strawberry vanilla frosting on top it's
got some pink streaks and it looks to be
stuffed with strawberry jam which sounds
amazing especially after all this
chocolate overdose
it's sweet
sweet oh my God it's nice though all
right it's time for our final donut and
this one is a bit of a boss battle so
this is a donut eclair it's called The
Breakup party eclair I guess because if
you go through a breakup this is what
you end up eating
so the first few bites were quite nice
they weren't as sweet and they didn't
feel as rich
but I realized most of the chocolate is
kind of centered towards the center of
the eclair and so it's a lot more
decadent the closer you get great for
breakups great as a metaphor for what
you feel when you're going through a
breakup and as a donut itself
pretty average both hot and cold
espresso and coffee drinks in the US
have options for flavors you can add as
flavor shots which are unsweetened or
flavored swirls which are sweet and
creamy now flavors unique to the US
include shots of vanilla toasted almond
blueberry raspberry and coconut and
flavor swirls you can get French vanilla
and pumpkin so I went ahead and had each
one of those Swirls and shots added to
one coffee right here in front of me
we'll call it the food Wars drinkaroo I
don't know what it is all the flavors in
one drink the lady when I ordered it was
like really and I was like really
[Music]
oh God so bad oh whoa this will whoa oh
man
it's like there's like an electric
charge to at the end I don't quite
understand
[Music]
this is poison don't get it all right
it's time for drinks let's start off
with the cold options that we have here
at Dunkin India uh the first one is a
classic lemonade let's go ahead and try
it it looks very clear
that's nice it's refreshing they've not
made it too sweet and I kind of like it
next up we have a virgin mojito
I don't see why somebody would go to
Dunkin Donuts get a donut and then a
virgin mojito on the side quick point to
make you can get them in a small bottle
or you can even get them in larger
options next up we have two flavors of
iced tea we have lemon and Peach I'm
gonna try the peach
if I had to pick one of these this is
the one I'd go for
exclusive hot drinks here in the US we
have these three uh the first one is
like a specific coffee blend at Duncan
called Duncan midnights
oh wow that has oh that is power that's
strong wow
it's like it's like really strong I kind
of love it moving on you give yourself a
chai latte
and doesn't have chai lattes what's
going on guys
that's really good and of course a
matcha latte no not matcha I hate matcha
that's the green one right beverages
that taste like lawn clippings
I hate it all right it's now time for
our milk based cold beverages here in
India we have a range of frappes some
iced chicken coffees let's start with
the frappes coffee
caramel and Hazelnut and they have a
seasonal flavor which is Alfonso mango
if you've not heard of the Alfonso
variety of mangoes it grows all over
here in India and it is the king of
mangoes you have to try it if you get a
chance I'm gonna start off with this one
because I love mango flavored anything
it's not bad next up we have some shaken
iced coffees in three flavors caramel
classic and hazelnut also the classic
flavored shaken iced coffee it's not as
sweet and I want to put this one on a
pedestal thank you
okay next up they also sell a ice mocha
and an iced latte it's time for the
chocolate milkshake and can I just say
looks decadent
it's quite thick
um it's kind of grainy you can taste the
graininess of the chocolate which I like
but I don't know if some some people
might not like that some people might
like really smooth chocolate milkshakes
okay so if you're traveling to India and
you must eat a Dunkin I would recommend
you have the Alphonse so mango frappe if
it's in season but I would also say
don't go to Dunkin go to any Juice Shop
you find them all across India and they
take fresh mangoes and they make you a
mango milkshake that will blow your mind
they'll put actual pieces of Alfonso
pulp in there and you'll chew on it
while you drink your milkshake God sense
so then they made these two hours ago
I'm sorry assume they don't look like
this anyway we have these cold drinks in
the US to call Refreshers they're
actually pretty good surprisingly I'm
starting down here we have the
strawberry dragon fruit I am such a
child it's spelled
[Music]
s-t-r-a-w-d-r-g-n-f-r-t and all I could
think of was Dragon farts
well that's actually pretty good Peach
Passion Fruit
an frt I keep thinking part of such a
child
whoa
what the hell I think all the syrup like
went to the bottom it's like way
stronger than it should be
yeah cause up top is really weak
somewhere in between there's a good sip
but I didn't find it anyway all right
Peach Passion Fruit coconut
oh but this is is that cool does that
work
okay
uh no
[Music]
oh gross yeah the coconut ones are bad
keeping it up on the cool drinks to get
yourself a frozen coffee a frozen matcha
latte a frozen chocolate and of course
the culados wait frozen hot chocolate
it's not just chocolate milk
oh man that is strong that is a
milkshake yo
it's not terrible it's this the flavor
is very strong this is apparently a blue
raspberry I think they have other
flavors but
once upon a time I worked at a movie
theater yes really when we figured out a
way to get into the syrup box because
found drinks with syrup and soda water
at the same time it mixes right when you
pour it in it was like a really dark
color and we dared each other drink it I
remember it was
so powerful I thought I was going to
throw up and I'd never experienced
anything like that powerful flavored
until today surprise surprise Dunkin
Donuts also serves chai so you have two
flavors this is ginger chai and we have
eliji chai elaichi is
cardamom ginger in Hindi is adrak and
it's just such a beautiful word to say
oh my God
they've gone heavy on the ginger for
sure
as advertised these do taste like
elaichi which is cardamom and ginger
yeah they don't quite have the the soul
of a chai that you get on the roadside
but I really love how Duncan has tried
to do this makes you feel a little bit
more at home so thank you Duncan
sandwiches and wraps and bagels and
breakfast stuff oh my get a good look
India we have a huge selection of
non-donary breakfast uh sandwiches
variety stuff you can get oh man I hit a
wall and I apologize
and I'm back you can get yourself maple
sugar bacon breakfast sandwich we have
these wake up wraps and wake up wraps
are I don't know really phoned in
breakfast tacos I don't know how to
describe it it's a tortilla they put the
stuff they already had for the
sandwiches in there they folded over
I'll just grab one you can get yourself
one and oh man this thing is like
hey everyone I'm watching this video in
the comments let me know I show you this
and then when I open it are you more
likely to eat this or less likely let me
know in the comments Duncan nobody wants
these you can get yourself a tomato
pesto grilled cheese Pesto's fine and
all but when something has pesto on it
you don't realize it doesn't look like
look at this green does that look like
we should go oh it's pesto or would you
be like oh I think that's moldy I also
got the grilled cheese oh
then you get yourself the sourdough
breakfast sandwich yo these things so
solidified probably edible a few hours
ago I'll I'll take a bite of this
sausage egg and cheese
no not bad bacon egg and Juice somewhere
encased in this melted cheese is bacon I
assure you there's also a turkey sausage
egg and cheese somewhere oh you can also
get bagels at your Dunkin Donuts why I
don't know but you can get bagels plain
cinnamon raisin multigrain sesame seed
and this one everything and get yourself
some cream cheeses including Garden
veggie strawberry and plain also you can
get an avocado spread which they did not
include
Duncan India you're not gonna believe
this our Dunkin Donuts you can get a
side of
you can get a side of something called
snack and bacon what snack and bacon you
ask it is
a bag of bacon Bagel minis you can get
plain and everything Bagels here's one
right now I think these have cream
cheese inside of them
yeah
I don't think I've ever had one of these
before
that's not a bad idea
not bad guys also in the U.S you can
order hash browns now at Dunkin Donuts
apparently you get these what do we call
these omelette bites uh you get bacon
egg and cheese or egg white and veggie
come on this is straight taken from from
Starbucks right we went to the Dunkin
India website and over there on the menu
they claim to sell burgers and a few
sides like nachos however we went to the
outlets and the manager said that
they're phasing out all Savory food and
Dunkin nationally but he was kind enough
to make us one single non-ridge burger
just so that we get to taste what it
would have been like it has a whole
chicken piece in there which is already
kind of nice some onions looks like
Tandoori mayo and the bun looks pretty
tasty
oh my God
that's actually really good I've done
many episodes of food Wars tasted many
burgers from restaurants that are
literally burger joints and this
literally Rivals those burgers this is
pretty good what's happening Duncan okay
so the fact is that Duncan has actually
scaled down massively here in India in
Bangalore where we're filming there used
to be 20 Dunkin Donut outlets now there
are only three so rumor has it that
Duncan might be phasing out of India in
general and the decision is going to be
made in the coming weeks so maybe this
video is the last remaining Legacy of
Duncan in India and this is probably the
last burger that has ever eaten oh you
this might be the guys this might be the
last Burger ever consumed from Dunkin
Donuts here in India
foreign
this large Americano is rupees 139 which
is currently 1.71 US dollars but keep in
mind at the time that we're filming this
the Indian Rupees at an all-time low so
hopefully things will get better and
this won't cost so much that same drink
in the US is 3.69 or
293.44 rupees that's a 63.9 percent
increase in price okay so the biggest
menu item that we have here in India is
our box of six now you can get two
categories you can get Classic Donuts
which are a lot simpler and it'll cost
you rupees 399 or you can get the
favorites Donuts which we have here
which are a lot more extravagant and
will cost you rupees 499 which amounts
to USD 6.12 right now if you want 12
donuts you need to get two boxes of six
which will cost you rupees 998. for food
our biggest menu item is a dozen donuts
18.73 or 1004
492.85 rupees
thank you our biggest drink is the box
of joe Avella it's the most expensive
single menu item 27.48 or
2190.25 rupees now in India we have
something called a Vada which is pretty
much a donut but it's Savory and it's
fried and I want to say that those costs
around 20 rupees while this original
glazed that I've bitten into a few times
costs 85 rupees so it's important to
note this price difference and people
here will definitely think about that
before buying something like this
[Music]
nikhail stop eating the props
okay so Dunkin Donuts India has not
released any of the nutritional info out
for the public and they've not gotten
back to us when we asked them for
information as of now however I can
confirm that one donut is probably less
nutritious than one salad
let's talk about dunking U.S nutrition
starting with the glazed donut in the
U.S it has 360 calories 22 grams of fat
10 grams of saturated fat 420 milligrams
of sodium or 20 39 grams of carbs and 18
grams of sugar and let's compare that
donut on to this one the Boston cream in
the USA a Boston cream is 270 calories
11 grams of fat 320 milligrams of sodium
39 grams of carbs and 18 grams of sugar
a Dunkin Donuts large ice Dunkin dark
roast coffee with cream and sugar in the
U.S is 260 calories 12 grams of fat and
37 grams of carbs now assuming that the
iced coffee is the same in the U.S and
India getting a large iced coffee with
cream and sugar and both the glazed and
a Boston cream donut has 890 calories
that's 35.6 percent of your daily
calorie intake yo
foreign
has not released any of their
ingredients to the public however there
is one huge difference between the U.S
and Indian donuts and that is that the
Indian Donuts are all eggless this is
because a huge percentage of Indians are
vegetarian especially Hindus and so they
even consider eating egg as non-veg food
and so yeah most fast food restaurants
have decided to not use egg in any of
their foods to make it more accessible
to a larger part of India but the US
does have it out of sight so I will
share with you the ingredients right now
first up the coffee regardless if you're
getting it hot or cold if you get a
plaque it's going to be 100 arabica
coffee nice now if you want to add cream
and sugar to it then you are adding milk
cream to sodium phosphate stabilizer
sodium citrate as a stabilizer and sugar
if you're going to be adding flavor to
your coffee drink one flavor you can get
both India and the US is Karma and in
the US our caramel flavor is made up of
all this
in the US our standard glazed donut is
made up of all of these things
you think that's a lot here's everything
in our Boston cream donuts
yikes that's a lot of words from calorie
counter portion sizes we wanted to find
out all the differences between Nando's
in the UK and India this is food Wars
if you're ordering chicken for one
person it comes in three sizes at a UK
Nando's
as a quarter chicken
as a half chicken or
as a whole chicken
for one person here in Nando's India
comes in the form of a quarter chicken
which is one piece or a half chicken
which is two pieces you can also get a
whole chicken but it only comes in the
form of a sharing platter the largest of
which is a jumbo platter two whole
chickens and five large sides I'm
excited to eat this but all I need now
is friends so
hit me up
the largest item in the UK is the family
platter it comes with two whole chickens
as well as five large sides a family of
one
I can eat this what about some other
things from the Nando's menu well in the
UK you can get a grilled chicken burger
in two sizes there's a single or as a
double Nando's India also sells chicken
burgers and offers customers the option
to double their chicken so you can get a
single chicken burger or double it to a
double chicken burger Nando's India
serves chicken wings but only in one
size a pack of four wings from a UK
Nando's come in four portion sizes as a
three piece there's a five piece there's
a ten piece and a 15 piece it's really
weird being the country with the biggest
sizes for a change Joe I miss you now
the classic side for any order of
Nando's in the UK is a side of Peri-Peri
chips I'm allowed to call them chips not
fries because Joey's not in this video
in the UK these come in two sizes
regular and large here in Nando's India
they're advertised not as chips but as
fries because that's what they are at
Harry you're weirdo I'm gonna weigh them
you get them in two sizes either regular
or large let me wear the regular
it's a hundred grams on the dot nice
next
418 grams no 408 grams 175 grams in the
large I don't know how to read
here is everything on the menu and a UK
now knows that you won't find in India
this is everything you'll find on the
menu at Nando's India that you will not
find in the UK we'll start with the
chicken now when you order chicken at
Nando's they'll ask you to pick a spice
level we have quite a few of these most
of which are shared with India except
for two firstly we have pimento spice I
think this is limited edition and it
sits somewhere between medium and hot on
the spice scale another exclusive spice
is Perry Tamer as the name suggests this
is quite a mild tame spice it's
somewhere between mild and basically
plain chicken I think it's a slightly
sweeter glaze than you might find on the
regular Peri-Peri spice here in India we
just get our chicken in the classic
scale of plain lemon and Herb mild
hot and extra hot I'm willing to bet
that our extra hot blows the UK extra
hot out of the water you see this tongue
this tongue can take spice oh my God is
this some kind of joke it's like
tickling me it's teasing me with spice
this is Child's Play I will say I love
how the UK Nando's has two extra flavors
I wish India Nando's experimented more
where in India dude there are so many
spices but what we lack in spices we
make up for in Mains number one creamy
cashew chicken with spicy rice
damn good okay now on to the next main
this is chicken cataplana cataplana is a
type of Portuguese clam shaped stove
cooking pot and they've also served it
with a yogurt dip so using a cataplan is
apparently healthier because you end up
using less fats to cook your meat and
your veggies next up we're having
chicken espetada or as I like to call it
chicken espet Tada I've been fired from
the show 16 times this season I imagine
they take the piece of chicken put them
on skewers put the marinade so Nando's
is a Portuguese inspired South African
restaurant so most of the recipes are
things that were developed by Portuguese
explorers when they were in South Africa
we also have a lot of Cuisine that's
inspired by our former Colonial
overlords back in Portugal in fact Goa
which is a small estate here in India
was where the Portuguese first settled
and so a lot of the cuisine is derived
and inspired by Portuguese Cuisine we
have a couple of chicken Mains of our
own starting with boneless thighs these
come in orders of four and you can get
them in any of the standard Nando's
spice levels and our other chicken
exclusive is this Wing roulette so Wing
roulette is an order of 10 wings and
it's a variety of the Nando's spices the
idea is that you'll get some of these
share them with your friends some of you
might get hit with an extra hot wing
whereas others might get off easy with a
mile when I go to Nando's I'm generally
going for medium or hot I'm not trying
to be a hero if I'm going for extra hot
I'm just not actually going to taste the
food it's just going to kind of hurt I
may also add a little bit of the kind of
garlic and herb sauce which adds a
little bit of spice to it or also I've
used ketchup in the past which my
friends have lambasted me for so don't
do that
good chicken though we also have some
meal deals these are more affordable
options and you will not find them in
the UK let's start off with the first
one which is pulled chicken sliders oh
my God this is like Gourmet dining I
think I would need to eat three of these
to feel considerably full Unfortunately
they only give you two next up is a
pulled chicken burger
oh my motherload of chicken that is a
lot of pulled chicken it needs a sauce
did I just eat a part that doesn't have
sauce next up we have chicken tegela
which is basically grilled chicken some
corn some roasted veggies and tomato and
this is served with some spicy rice
they've also given like a bunch of
veggies is really trying to get our
vitamins in but take a look at the
tegela itself it's got a bed of rice
underneath but on top there's some
pulled chicken a lot of grilled onions
and a lot of finely chopped capsicum
next up you have the option of a pulled
chicken wrap I mean
it looks like a wrap or you can also get
a pulled chicken pita
damn this looks like a donor Kebab I
guess the true test of whether Nando's
is putting a lot of effort into their
food is whether they're wraps and their
uh
Pita tastes good
let's go
miles better than any other fast food
restaurant alongside those you can get a
tub of veggies so next up is chicken
skewers for a kebab eating Nation
good job Manus you get these along with
some pita bread and a couple of Salsas
you get a yogurt sauce and some salsa
next up we have Portuguese chicken and
gravy and if you can't tell from my face
I'm having a great time
oh boy
look at that it looks like there's
tadkan top dude oh my God what is a
tadka you ask basically it's the best
way to finish up a curry here in India
we take oil heat it add some spices in
there temper them and then pour them
over our Curry and our final meal deal
dish is Saucy chicken strips in spicy
rice I'm not gonna lie this one looks
like the most boring option out of
everything here let's look at some of
the burgers and wraps from Nando's in
the UK we have a couple of exclusive
options firstly we have the sunset
burger if I had to hazardous as to why
this is called the sunset Burger it
might be because you kind of get a
sunset yellow orange red effect going
with the cheese the chicken and the
Chutney which looks very pretty
I haven't had this before I wouldn't
normally order it at Nando's but it's
actually very very good the bun is
slightly different to the regular burger
buns that we get it's a little bit more
kind of spongy and pillowy and that
Chutney stuff is delicious very sweet a
little bit Smoky then we also have the
Fino Peta I really love the packaging of
this it's great for delivery you just
tear straight through the middle not
like that
and then pop that off
you have a nicely preserved upright
bitter now in a filo Pizza you get
chicken thighs you get some salad you
get perones you get halloumi and I think
there's also some caramelized onions in
there as well I'll be honest I'm going
to Nando's this is what I'm getting it's
kind of got all my favorite Nando's
things in one little package they took
it off the menu for the pandemic they've
recently brought it back which I am
thrilled about because I missed it
dearly
The Cheeky Nando's levels off the charts
right now we have a couple of exclusive
burgers and wrap flavors of our own
starting with the
salad wrap
I kind of like their packaging
let's see how this tastes
that is a messed up way to eat a wrap
eat it from the top not from the side
please nikhil
wow next up is the petty cheeseburger
which also comes as a wrap or in Pita
form look at the juice is dripping off
this thing man
that's what I'm talking about this
flavor has just achen India by storm in
the past few decades it's part of the
trifecta of ingredients that are red
velvet matcha and periperi the people
just love to put into every menu over
here Peri-Peri if you don't know is a
spice mix that was discovered by
Portuguese explorers when they were
settling slash pillaging South African
countries like South Africa and
Mozambique on the subject of foreigners
coming to a place and taking things from
it I would like to formally apologize to
India from the UK feel free to come and
take your stuff back from the British
museum whatever's convenient I feel like
most Indians identify Peri-Peri as the
little packets of Peri Peri you get at
McDonald's and you pour them into your
fries and shake them to get Peri-Peri
fries I feel like when they come to
Nando's they might find it not spicy
enough if you don't eat meat now this is
actually pretty good for vegetarian and
vegan options in the UK first up we have
the great imitator wrap it doesn't look
very appealing right now however the
great imitator is Nando's version of
fake chicken I think it's made with pea
protein and by all accounts I've heard
it's pretty good they we have the beanie
Burger
as the name would suggest it's a bean
Patty also comes with I believe an
egg-free Mayo some salad as well then we
have a spiced chickpea Burger it's kind
of similar to the beanie Burger however
once again as the name would suggest the
Patty is predominantly made of chickpeas
this one actually mirrors the sunset
Burger a little more because it's got
the same bun and also has some of that
red pepper Chutney and then finally we
have a portobello mushroom and halloumi
Pitta it's a pita bread with a big
portobello mushroom inside as well as
some salad some halloumi and more of
that red pepper Chutney pretty much
everything
found here in India serves vegetarian
food because a huge percentage of the
country is vegetarian having said that
Nando's actually had quite a few
non-vegetarian options which is very
cool to see in a restaurant like this so
let's go off the list of vegetarian food
now starting with creamy cashew paneer
and spicy rice so this is the same thing
as the creamy cashew chicken except
they've replaced it with chunks of
cottage cheese and it just looks
delicious let's see if Nando's has done
paneer right
it's really nice and it's not as chewy
it's soft soft paneer at a fast food
chain unheard of the next vegetarian
dish is called something exotic it's a
mystery even they don't know what it
could be and it is
what the heck I okay I did not expect to
see this it's watermelon and paneer
you know Nando's watermelon and paneer
you really are walking the line between
creativity and Abomination
no those are kind of weird together but
I think overall it was a fun dish and
they serve it along with a three bean
salad the three beans are
chickpea rajma and some other one let's
taste
even this is flavorful what's going on
okay now we're moving on to a vegetarian
version of the cataplana they have
tossed the same vegetables but this time
along with paneer and some chickpea I'm
gonna taste the chickpea
very nice this is easily the best food
I've had in food Wars
hands
okay next up we have a vegetarian
version of the espetada as well
look at this
this is probably the best wedge skewer
I've seen in my life it's just too
beautiful I can't eat it I must frame
this
in my home also they serve garlic bread
because this isn't enough apparently the
first one is a veg burger they serve it
with coleslaw
it's a runny milk frozen patty it's all
right this is probably the most
underwhelming thing on the menu so far
and finally they have a mushroom and
paneer Burger both of these options you
can get along with a wrap or pita
they have put a huge chunk of paneer in
there have you seen a paneer this big I
didn't even know they made this
Super Burger when there's good food in
the show I'm so happy
and that's not all there are more
vegetarian options from the meal deal
section let's go from the top first off
we have wedge sliders these ones have
patties instead of pulled chicken next
up you can get a veg together this one
has paneer so same thing it's a bed of
rice some chopped veggies on top with
paneer as the protein it's served along
with potato wedges next up we have
paneer skewers that you can get along
with either spiced rice or with some
pita bread very similar to the skewers
we had with chicken and they seem to
have the same sauce as well they're
served along with either pita bread or
spice rice you can choose which option
of side and you also get a salsa as well
as a yogurt dip I always feel like it's
hard to do skewers with paneer because
it's such a delicate ingredient that if
you fry too much it gets too rubbery oh
is that a piece of pineapple then oh
it's a lot of thought put into these
dishes Nando's is a class apart it's
just a class apart and finally we have a
very simple option at the end it's a
roasted veg and some grilled paneer I'd
probably skip this one next up the UK
exclusive starters first up we've got
some sweet potato wedges and garlic
perinas
for some reason they've also mixed in a
bunch of regular chips as well I don't
know if that's normal because I'm
traditionally not going to order sweet
potato fries if you've watched free Wars
for a long time you'll know my thoughts
on sweet potato namely that they are bad
it's just like someone took a chip
and went how can we make this floppier
I know
the garlic Pyrenees however very tasty
would recommend getting a side of this
next time you're in Nando's also
exclusive to the UK are Peri-Peri nuts
you can start your meal off with a
combination of I think cashews almonds
and maybe macadamia nuts all coated in
their signature Peri-Peri spice I'm
usually pretty good at this let's find
out
in the UK you can also get fried
halloumi sticks and a dip of your choice
however unfortunately the restaurant
forgot ours here's what they're supposed
to look like
neither of these are exclusive but in
both countries you can also start with
hummus and olives India has a variety of
options starting with the cheesy Fiesta
fries seems pretty straightforward but
let's see if it is a fiesta oh my God
bro their presentation is off the charts
look at this
every Marvel at the presentation
okay I will say these have been in the
cold for a while so they may not taste
as good as when they're fresh
and I am right next up they have cheesy
Fiesta Chicken
boom let's pull chicken grilled onions
same cheese and I imagine there's fries
underneath next up they have something
called the sweet potato and corn snack
whoa why is their food so beautiful just
corn there's uh bits of red paprika some
chopped parsley but also it's pieces of
thinly sliced lemon
that's new
oh
are you supposed to eat that it's
interesting I don't know if I'd serve
lemon pieces in my salad next up we have
uh four piece wings but these ones are
spicy Tangy Wings they look quite
delicious
sprinkle some lemon on there
I'm disproportionately jealous of that
little lemon wedge with the wings why
don't we have that very little touch
lovely bit of freshness to your wing
forget about it I have to be honest
pretty bland not tasting any spice not
getting any Tang these are the most
underwhelming things on the menu so far
and now for something I did not expect
to see on the Nando's menu at all we
have a creamy cashew paneer and chicken
naan more like Nando's am I right guys
[Music]
bro why is all their food looking like
art that I can hang up on my wall okay
so this nun has the chicken so this is
the naan veg naan let's go ahead and
take a bite see how it tastes
it's damn good the gravy on top is very
similar to a butter chicken it's got a
lot of sweetness and richness you can
tell there's cashew in it but they've
also sprinkled on a lot of green chili
some coriander and chopped onions so
there is a nice thicker spice and
they've just drizzled a lot of Malai on
top so it's creamy this is what it would
be like if India had to have a pizza
banging also they serve it with
something called perines dip are you
sure this is for this
let's just avoid
it's just like a huge tub of mayonnaise
but it's perines apparently father is
looking for a healthier option Nando's
also offers salads there are two main
options in the UK firstly we have this
quinoa and Peri tomato salad this
actually looks pretty good I have to say
it looks like kind of sun-dried tomatoes
some lettuce some dressing some of these
little crunchy Crouton cracker things
and of course quinoa and our other salad
option is the delightfully named Rainbow
Bowl
now the very colorful rainbow bowl comes
with some hummus some coleslaw some
tennis and broccoli there's some grains
down in the corner and I think some
shredded carrot as well I love
tenderstem broccoli and we'll fight for
the deaf tennis and roughly
by default the salads come plain but you
can also add chicken breast chicken
thighs fake chicken or beanie patties to
any of them here at Nando's India we
have salad options of our own starting
with the Mediterranean salad
is that something Mediterranean next up
we have an Algarve salad looks pretty
much the same minus the olives plus some
cashew nuts and a lot of sun-dried chili
or tomatoes then we have a quinoa salad
for those of you who are monsters and
can't eat rice like a normal person and
finally we have a Caesar salad and the
Caesar salad comes with a dressing now
all of those salads we ordered are
vegetarian but you can optionally get
some chicken strips if you need more
protein in there then we're on to the
sides in the UK you can get quite a few
exclusive sides to go along with your
Peri-Peri chips first up we have rainbow
slaw which is coleslaw filled with
Skittles no it's not it's just Coastal
kind of colorful we also have a mixed
leaf salad
no box of leaves now there's some tomato
and cucumber in there as well this one
is spiced grains with butternut squash
which actually sounds pretty good some
grains in there I think that's feta
cheese
some green beans and butternut squash
next up we have creamy mashed potato
it's mashed potato you can also get a
side of just some long stem broccoli
this one looks a little more sad than
the one that was on the salad but still
great
some garlic in there as well nice touch
and then finally we can get Macho peas
peas for Macho men just like me
[Music]
I wasn't really sure where to put these
but there are a couple of extra things
which you can add on to pretty much any
order so I guess they kind of count as
sides first you can just buy a couple of
pieces of grilled halloumi from anandos
in the UK for those of you who don't
know halloumi is a cheese which I think
is made with sometimes a mixture of
sheep and goat's milk predominantly
produced in Cyprus it's an interesting
cheese when you bite into it it doesn't
really give it's got a kind of like
rubbery texture I personally find it
very satisfying to eat as do a lot of
British people I think we're responsible
for something like 80 of the Cypress
halloumi consumption in the world which
is kind of wild but yeah it's pretty
good
it like squeaks on your teeth when you
eat it the other sorts of side options
include just one whole portobello
mushroom
this might have looked okay when it was
hot you can also just get a single plain
tortilla from Nando's
I guess the idea is that you could kind
of buy maybe the halloumi the mushroom
and a couple of other bits and sauces
and create your own wrap or own burrito
situation
personally
don't think it's worth doing that just
buy a pre-assembled one options for
sides here at an Indian Nando's you can
get potato wedgies I already showed
veggies no no they're not veggies the
potato wedges run in the middle potato
wedges you can also get some Char
grilled veg in fact they give you a lot
you can also get a three bean salad
which looks really colorful and has like
a soupy liquid that I want to try
[Music]
lentil soup you say nay I want three
bean salad water
next up we have a Portuguese salad looks
pretty straightforward I have no idea
what makes this Portuguese is it the
olives probably and finally you can just
get a tub of feta cheese they've given
me six cubes of feta cheese yeah
cool Nando's actually has quite a few
dessert options in the UK if you're in
store many of the shops will have an
option for bottomless frozen yogurt so
you can have that in the flavors of
vanilla strawberry chocolate or mango
install and also on delivery you can get
a few more options including a Nauti
NATA this is Nando's take on a
Portuguese egg custard tart AKA Pasto de
nada
probably butcher the pronunciation of
that if I take myself out to Nando's and
I'm feeling uh bougie I'll probably end
my meal with one of these because I love
these things we can also get a salted
caramel brownie I don't know that it's
very pretty it's got little gold
sprinkles on it
I'm describing More Foods as pretty it's
been the theme of today but they are
kind of pretty next we have a chocolate
cake
which is a slice of what looks like a
pretty good gooey kind of indulgent
chocolate cake
pretty moist and then we also have this
gooey caramel cheesecake
this is actually really good I'm a
cheesecake fan but this is a great
example of a cheesecake I had it for the
first time I think when we filmed the UK
versus US Nando's go watch it now highly
recommend we don't shed any desserts
with the UK but we have our own desserts
starting with an ice cream and hot
chocolate where they don't deliver it so
here's an image of it I guess looks
pretty good looks nice then we have a
series of cakes starting with a
chocolate cake it's parcel in a burger
case which is kind of weird but dude
look at this it's a thick moist
fat cake I must taste for science
appropriately humid next up a red velvet
cake what did I say the trifecta of
ingredients I am surprised there's no
matcha milkshake at the end of this they
have to fit in red velvet in every
restaurant Peri-Peri red velvet and
matcha
and finally we have an out and out
cheesecake honestly all these desserts
are okay I probably skip the dessert
here last but by no means the least
let's talk about the drinks if you go
into a restaurant at bernardo's in the
UK you can get bottomless fizzy drinks
including coke diet coke Coke Zero
Sprite and Fanta now some people will
ask for a free glass of tap water and
then use that other fizzy drink
fountains to help themselves to free
fizzy drinks but I personally have
definitely never done that and would not
encourage that kind of flagrantly
illegal Behavior whatsoever
on delivery we do also have a few
exclusive drink options the first
options are these bottle green cordials
for those of you who aren't familiar
with cordials it's like a flavor
concentrate so what you'll do is you'll
put a few splashes of this into a glass
top it up with water and then you have a
drink which you can actually consume I
kind of thought these would come
pre-mixed so I was a little bit
surprised to see just bottles of The
Cordial itself but I guess if you can uh
make yourself some squash at home this
is Rooibos
where I don't
robust teas which are flavored with
things like lemon Peach and Berry and
finally we have gingerella by Karma
drinks this is just a ginger ale we can
also get bottomless soda refills here in
India but our bottled options are fresh
lime soda and two iced tea options I
don't know fresh lime soda is a big
thing abroad but over here in India it
is the number one drink for middle class
families when you go to their family
each person of the family has a
different order for fresh lime soda Some
Like It with just salt some like it just
sweet Some Like It with sweet and salt
and some monsters like it with no salt
or sugar this is from a company called
Brew House a tea brewing company this is
supposed to be a Mojito lemon iced tea
it's nice and next a peach iced tea
Mandos also offers these drinks called
designer drinks which seem to be
non-alcoholic soft drink cocktails it
seems like they just took seven up and
Blended them to form different flavors
with different colors but I'm curious to
see if they actually taste good color
color which color do you choose let's
try the Virgin mojito ah tastes like a
Mojito without the alcohol
you can see they've gone the extra mile
they're putting fresh lemon a lot of
mint in there
next one is Citra which I assume is a
Mandarin slash orange flavor drink
very delicious super refreshing I
thought this could be something we could
make fun of Nando's for but they've
actually made some delicious refreshing
drinks if dip do the cats got the flu
the dogs got the chickenpox and so have
you Portuguese lemonade let's go what
makes it Portuguese I don't know maybe
it's olive oil let's see this is really
yum so it's not all sweet it has like
some sort of powder at the bottom is it
Peri-Peri powder I don't know but it
tastes like Chaat powder that they put
in a lot of lemon sodas here in India
and it's really yum Peach and
elderflower they've actually put a slice
of peach in there these are certified
designer drinks
half a chicken Peri-Peri chips and
garlic bread at a UK Nando's will cost
you 13 pounds and 10 pence that same
meal in India will cost you rupees 869
which at the time of filming this video
is equal to 9.85 pounds that's almost 25
percent cheaper of a meal than the one
in the UK okay now while you Brits might
feel hard done by because of these price
differences I must say that this is
actually super expensive for a single
meal for a single person here in India
in fact most people in this country
would find that almost aspirational you
can get meals here for close to 100
rupees that's less than a pound I would
say that I can't even consider this fast
food it is the most expensive restaurant
we've tried here on food Wars but the
food was Top Class throughout so I guess
it makes sense now Nando's does have
some slightly more affordable options in
the form of meal deals where you can get
a single meal for around 400 rupees
which is equal to 4.5 pounds this
doesn't seem like a significant upgrade
and it isn't in fact the state that
we're filming this video is Karnataka
here in India and the daily wage is
around 500 rupees so you would have to
literally work an entire day to afford a
single meal here in Nando's in fact my
first salary as an intern was 10 000
rupees per month which is 125 pounds per
month and so if I ordered a cheeky
Nando's it would literally be nearly one
tenth of my entire monthly salary I'm
not sure what consider Nando is an
affordable option in the UK and I'm not
even really sure I'd consider it fast
food it sit somewhere in that kind of
fast casual bracket combining elements
of fast food restaurants with elements
of the more traditional dining
experience some Brits don't really like
Nando's and might claim that it's kind
of overrated I personally love Nando's
it's fast it's consistent and I have a
kind of cultural attachment to it as I
was kind of a teenager when it really
blew up in popularity here in the UK I
might be able to get more value for
money at somewhere like a KFC but to me
it wouldn't hit the same
unfortunately Nando's in the UK doesn't
disclose a full ingredients list Nando's
in India also doesn't disclose a full
ingredient list so what do we know about
the food well the FAQ pages on our
respective websites do share some clues
for example in the UK Nando says it uses
red tractor assured chicken from British
Farms to be red tractor certified
chickens must be raised with certain
benefits such as no cages and natural
lights the Indian FAQ page says that all
of Fernando's Chicken in India is
sourced from India and it's all
cage-free they also say that all the
chickens are a grade now I don't know
what this means because it's hard to
keep up with up-to-date poultry
practices here in India but one report
from 2012 said that a top grade chicken
must be free of deformities that detract
from its appearance or that affect the
normal distribution of Flesh slight
deformities such as slightly curved or
dented breast bones and slightly curved
backs may be present now this sounds
kind of vague but I do hope that Nando's
is following this practice and only
sourcing some a grade chickens because
that's what it tasted like some a great
chicken one other thing we can glean
from the FAQ page is that the great
imitator wrap might not be as
plant-based as Nando seems to think it
is this is because both the tortilla
wrap and also the glaze used on the
chicken contains shellac Sherlock is a
substance used in food as a glazing
agent but it's found in various other
things such as nail polish fireworks and
sealants The Twist is that it's
technically an animal product it's a
resin secreted by lack beetles female
lack beetles will secrete it onto trees
in the forests of India and Thailand
where it's then harvested processed and
sold for use the bugs countless animals
for the purpose of veganism I'm a meat
eater so I can't really talk but in my
opinion I don't think a bug should count
I think that's fine from Gary kind of
person says we want to find out all the
differences between Cadbury chocolates
in the UK and in India this is food Wars
Cadbury dairy milk in India comes in
ranges of four sizes number one is
Cadbury dairy milk minis it comes in
this large packet with 18 smaller pieces
of 7 grams each our smallest of these
bite size 11 gram bars then we have
these 18 gram little bars a simple 24
grams tiny one next up we have our
multi-pack bars which weigh 33.5 grams
the standard individual Dairy Milk Bar
weighs 45 grams your Duo bar which comes
in two halves and weighs 54.4 grams then
a 55 grams Maha pack next up we have
this 110 gram bar family pack 126 grams
then we move to a 180 gram bar we have
this 360 gram bar
the biggest size you'll find in the UK
is an 850 gram giant bar
so in India Cadbury is really well known
for its gift boxes in fact they've done
so much marketing over so many years
that it's become synonymous with
festivals like Diwali dasera and even
Christmas and New Year's on their
website right now you can get anything
from an anniversary tin box to a Ramadan
tin box and they come in several
different sizes for starters there's a
standard personalized gift box which
contains six Cadbury dairy milk bars
three of which are silk and three of
which are standard and that's the one we
have right here in fact they've put my
face on it I mean that's a whole lot of
packaging for normal bars of chocolate
you can just buy I guess it even says
food was oh it says US versus India
sorry Harry apart from this you can also
get a larger personalized birthday gift
box which will contain 450 gram silk
bars three birthday whistles a large
Banner a birthday hat so the next time
you don't know what to do for your
birthday just order this to your house
and you can have a party by yourself now
we have some gift box items of our own
but they usually come more in the form
of of selection boxes these are most
commonly seen around Christmas time at
which point cadburys will release Heroes
and Roses which are selection boxes
containing 600 grams of individually
wrapped chocolates it's a real tradition
in British households to have a few of
these lying around the other options
include quality Street and celebrations
people tend to have their own favorites
when it comes to the selection boxes and
also the chocolates inside them I think
generally Heroes would be my preferred
option over roses I prefer the kind of
more mainstream chocolate bars that
you'll find including little whisper
bites which I think might be my favorite
if you want a gift option for all year
round up for a milk tray these have been
around for decades I think my mum used
to be giving these to people when she
was growing up and for the run-up to
Christmas you've got to get yourself an
advent calendar I don't think I'd
normally go for one of these these are a
little bit flimsy quite narrow but still
you get a lot of Joy from opening a tiny
bite of chocolate every morning and then
run up to Christmas
in India that
you find in the UK here are all the
Cadbury products from the UK that you
won't find in India this is so much
chocolate in terms of our classic dairy
milk flavors we have two exclusives
number one roast almond and number two
crackle this used to be my favorite as a
child but right now I really like this
delicious chunks of roast almond we have
some exclusive dairy milk flavors of our
own firstly for the health conscious
among us we have this 30 less sugar
dairy milk I guess this could be helpful
as well if you find regular milk
chocolate too sweet which some people do
but then I guess just opt for some dark
chocolate instead next up we have
Cadbury caramel it's a bar of dairy milk
but inside each square there's a little
bit of caramel this is one of my
favorite ones it does get a little bit
sickly if you eat too much of it because
of the amount of sugar but very tasty we
have some big taste bars which are
chunky versions of dairy milk starting
with peanut caramel crisp and we also
have a triple chopped sensation big
Taste Bar which combines dark milk and
white chocolate in one delicious bar
these ones look really cool they've
definitely put a bit more thought into
the design of the bars tastes really
good so
next up we've got dairy milk with
crunchy bits now this is crunchy with an
ie not crunchy with a Y crunchy with an
ie is actually a bar of chalk that you
can get here in the UK it's milk
chocolate with a honeycomb Center then
we have a Dairy Milk dime bar
dime is another chocolate bar which
dairy milk has kind of collabed with I
think it's like a very thin brittle
almond caramel bar with a little bit of
chocolate on the outside my granddad
released the light dime then we have
this marvelous Creations jelly popping
candy bar as the name suggests it's a
bar of chocolate which contains some
popping candy as well as I think jelly
beans I've not tried this in a long time
I want to see what the ratios are like
and also if I can really feel the
popping candy you can see like a couple
of bits of I assume jelly beans peeking
out the top the pattern is kind of odd
usually obviously you have squares makes
it nice and easy to break apart and
share I'm just going to bite into it
like a madman
you really do get the popping candy my
mouth is popping
but it's actually not too bad you get
little chewy Sweet bits in with your
chocolate there's a lot going on but I
don't hate it for vegans in the UK
Cadbury's also has a plant-based bar
I've never tried this so I want to see
if I can taste the difference between
this and dairy milk
it looks like chocolate
definitely does Taste of almond which is
okay because I quite like kind of nut
and chocolate as a combination if I went
vegan I don't know if I'd be rushing to
the store to buy this it's okay the
texture is pretty good but the flavor
just really isn't there our last two
exclusive dairy milk bars are actually a
mystery two bars which contain fillings
of a mystery flavor you try and guess
what the flavor is and then you can
submit your answer online myself and the
rest of the crew have now got to try
these and give our best guesses mystery
bulb one oh gosh last time I threw stuff
at you it didn't go very well
got it oh okay it's fruity currently
we're thinking maybe Rose I'm personally
thinking apricot struggling to agree
here we can't taste more
fruit while we figure that one out we'll
try Mystery by number two now this one
smells aggressively fruity catch Leon
I'm getting quite a lot of like very
artificial raspberry flavor I'd be
fairly confident in a certain amount of
raspberry it might be blueberry plot
twist they've already revealed the
flavors we didn't know first one was
rhubarb and custard classic British
dessert didn't really get very close to
that one second was blue raspberry which
we actually did kind of get I personally
don't think I would buy either of those
again though maybe the first one you
don't mind it and now for a silk range
or as Cadbury's trying to rebranded the
S range what is this some sort of new
iPhone but whether you call it silk or S
I love these chocolates first off we
have the typical silk it basically it's
just dairy milk but a lot silkier then
we have dairy milk silk bubbly it's
dairy milk silk but bubbly yes nice
light Airy next you have a Dairy Milk
silk fruit and nut then we have dairy
milk silk hazelnut wow there are some
proper large chunks of hazelnut the
hazelnut itself the flavor of it really
lends to the chocolate and it doesn't
taste as sweet next up we have dairy
milk silk roast almond we have dairy
milk silk mousse they've tried to
recreate the flavor of mousse and you
can see that it's a lot more fudgy the
chocolate inside it's all right
oh man there's one that I'm scared to
try dairy milk silk bubbly bubble gum oh
no I saw the color of it oh my God why
have they done this growing up we had a
bubble gum called Boomer which is now
what we have all become that one bite
was really not that bad it definitely
tastes like bubble gum and gave me that
Boomer Vibe that's as much as I can have
of that now to cleanse the palette silk
Oreo um
that is a nice flavor you would I use my
favorite out of a lot we also have
another variation of Oreo it's red
velvet Oreo if you watched previous
episodes of food wash you remember that
one of the ingredients that has taken
India by storm in the past few decades
is red velvet and I have tasted this
before and I actually think it's really
good but it is overkill it's literally
dairy milk silk the Oreo white cream and
chunks of Oreo that have been turned
into red velvet
you have a treadmill finally we have
dairy milk silk heart blush I imagine
you give this to your loved one it says
pull over here and I'm pretty excited
for this
Never Gonna Give You Up Never Gonna Let
You Down I can't believe I've been
rickrolled in my own video at the back
there is a very elaborate looking tear
tab so I'm just gonna ah
not very easy to wait what
I'd probably break up with whoever gave
me this at this point this is
frustrating it's more Packaging all
right
more packaging this is honestly a very
wasteful way to tell somebody you like
them there you go it's some pink
chocolate oh my God I swear to God if
it's the same as the bubble gum I'm
gonna cry
it's not bubblegum so
this is actually quite a fun experience
I'm not gonna like
yeah we don't have silk bars but we do
have something called Dark milk
Cadbury's has kind of invented this
hybrid milk and dark chocolate for
someone whose tastes like somewhere
between those two there is the dark milk
dark milk also comes in variations
including a salted caramel flavor and a
hazelnut flavor I feel like they've
tried to Market these a little bit more
at adults maybe as opposed to kids the
packaging kind of gives a slightly more
sophisticated vibe sexy if you will at
the other end of the scale we have some
even sweeter options than classic milk
chocolate firstly we have Cara milk
which is golden caramel chocolate this
one I have not tried I'm kind of
intrigued I'm gonna have a bite I worry
it's going to be far too sweet
wow that's very sweet you do get notes
of caramel but I really don't think I
could eat more than a couple of bites of
that and of course we also just have
white chocolate as I've said I'm not
really a big fan of white chocolate and
I don't think I'm alone in that because
this basically wasn't available in any
of the big supermarkets that I looked in
the shop we were able to track it down
in was poundland which is a shop in the
UK where everything costs a pound I know
it sounds ridiculous to an American
audience but that is what it's called
you can find Cadbury boneville dark
chocolate in both the UK and in India
but there's a slight difference in the
UK the packaging is bright red and over
here we have different flavors 50 dark
chocolate and 70 dark chocolate I have
uh all the years grown to like dark
chocolate I was never a fan of it
growing up but 70 dark chocolate I don't
know oh
you know it's not as bitter as I
expected very creamy also the cocoa is
100 sustainably sourced next up we have
a fruit and nut it's got a peanut in
there
it doesn't taste as heavy as the other
chocolates I've had so far and I really
appreciate this am I growing old is that
what's happening and the final flavor is
cranberry which have been the most
excited about I don't think I've had any
chocolate bars that have had cranberry
in them but obviously cranberry and dark
chocolate sounds like an amazing
combination that is so good the tartness
of the cranberry and like the slight
sugeriness really complements the dark
chocolate it's a crunch of roasted
almond it's a winner real nice I like
this range of bone Wheels feels like a
healthier guilty pleasure we also have
some boneville products you'll find in
the UK that you won't find in India
firstly we have Bonville old Jamaica the
old Jamaica refers to rum and raisin
flavors added to the dark chocolate and
we also have an orange bourneville I
personally don't love dark chocolate and
I especially do not love dark chocolate
combined with fruit so I'm respectfully
not going to try any of these if you're
wondering where the name bournville
comes from it's actually a village that
was created by the Cadbury family for
workers who worked in the factory near
Birmingham Bonville still exists today
so you can go and visit it it's home to
Cadbury World which is a kind of Cadbury
Museum interactive experience thing and
apparently it's a really nice place to
live and now it's time for all of the
remaining Indian Cadbury products
starting with Cadbury
fuse
their tagline for this is a delicious
chocolatey Feast like some sort of
chocolatey mousse in the middle
surrounded by caramel and then the outer
layer of chocolate has peanuts in it so
I can imagine this being a proper Feast
kinda nice I think I could eat this much
of one chocolate but the fact that I'm
eating so many varieties of chocolate
one after the other is really doing
something to my brain like why are we
doing this no like what is this why are
we tasting all of this what is the point
of this show next in line we have the
Cadbury
crispello I want to be on the team that
gets to name all of these chocolates
seems like you can just get away with
anything it's clearly filled with some
rice krispies and things that are
Crispies hey this one is actually really
um next up
Cadbury 5 Star 3D if you don't know what
5 star is it's basically the chocolate
that made caramel cool in India it's
been around for decades and actually fun
fact it's my mom's favorite chocolate
now they've upgraded to Five Star 3D
what's the difference between this and
any other five star it has nuts I will
say having eaten the past three
chocolates in a row I'm starting to
realize they're kind of the same thing
it's decent I prefer the original five
star that one Sparks Nostalgia this one
just feels too modern next up we have a
perk so perk is another chocolate that's
been around in India for ages now and
it's gone through a lot of Evolutions
like every other chocolate has now they
sell pork in a double pack it says you
can rip it share it
oh
next up some gemstones that's right the
UK didn't give us our gemstones back but
they definitely gave us gems
yeah I mean fair enough sorry guys so
they're M M's without the m m branding
on top what I used to as a kid you'd get
a small packet of gems and I would suck
on each gem until the color would come
off and it would be a white gem then I'd
put all the white ones in my mouth and
bite them like one big chocolate that
was weird and I had no friends Cadbury
Temptations rum and raise rum and uh
Cadbury Cadbury
Cadbury Temptations almond treat it
smells like rum
whoa I did not expect that flavor to be
so strong can they sell this to Children
it kind of tastes like a Christmas Ram
cake yeah I don't mind it I think this
could be a great Christmas
sort of chocolate to have around next up
is my favorite childhood chocolate
nutties I freaking love nutties and my
favorite part about nutties is that The
Branding has not really changed for like
decades now what this chocolate is is
basically Cadbury chocolate coated over
a cashew nut that's covered in nubit
oh my God that is so good then we have a
load more Cadbury exclusives in the UK
and we'll start with the bars we'll
start with what is technically a Cadbury
product but initially was not this is
the fries chocolate cream bar it's a
dark chocolate bar with a creamy smooth
fondant Center a fun fact is that the
fries were a Quaker family who were the
first ones to actually commercially
produce chocolate bars in the UK before
the fries came along drinking chocolate
was kind of the only way to consume it
fries also makes a peppermint cream bar
as well as Turkish delight I will say
this is not the best Turkish delight out
there if you want Turkish delight go to
a grocery store that sells Turkish food
get some classic stuff whereas this is a
kind of slightly cheapy Turkish delight
encased in chocolate next up we have
Boost bars these are chocolate bars
filled with caramel and biscuit pieces
when boost was first launched I think
they were kind of marketed as almost
like an energy bar they had loads of
sugar and glucose in them although I
think they have now recently dropped
that down and it's just in line more
with a standard chocolate bar then we're
on two Chomps I personally love a chop
these were also a little bit hard to
find I think we have to go to poundland
for these ones as well but they used to
cost like 10p from your local news
agents it's just like a chocolate bar
with toffee caramel inside simple but
effective then we have crunchy bars
which are chocolate bars with a large
honeycomb Center personally don't love
crunchy bars I don't love the texture of
the honeycomb and they're very very
sweet what I do love however is a curly
whirly these are brilliantly named they
come in these little individual bars
like this they look a bit weird it's
kind of a web of chocolate and caramel
I used to have braces as a kid and I
really missed toffee and caramel while I
had them on moving on we have a double
decker bar a nod to the British double
decker buses this is a two layered
chocolate bar with a nougal layer as
well as a kind of crunchy pieces and
caramel layer I like these next up we
have fudge bars we've got these little
bite-sized ones today I like these the
guys seem to disagree with me but I
think these are good I will opt for
these in a Heroes box it's just a bar a
fudge covered with chocolate then we
move on to the picnic bar it's a
chocolate bar that contains I think
caramel some rice crispy kind of pieces
as well as some raisins and peanuts now
while India has a Five Star Bar in the
UK we just have a Star Bar I don't think
I've ever had one of these before
apparently it's milk chocolate with
caramel and peanut let's give it a try
that might get added to my rotation you
know that's pretty good next up we have
the twirl these are like ribboned
chocolate bars which are then kind of
cased within more chocolate it leads to
quite an interesting texture and quite a
nice taste the only issue with Twirls is
that they do crumble and kind of go
everywhere you can also get 12s in
orange flavor then we're on to whisper
bars I don't really know how they make
these because it's milk chocolate but
it's like aerated there's kind of little
holes all the way through it we put a
man on the moon and we aerated a
chocolate bar the result is a really
nice texture actually it sort of melts
in your mouth when you eat it I have
some American colleagues in the US last
time I visited this was the one thing
they asked me to bring over you can also
get whisper gold bars these are the same
as regular Whispers but they have a
layer of caramel running along the top
and the last but by no means this bar is
the Fredo it's basically just a tiny
piece of solid milk chocolate in the
shape of Fredo the Frog but for people
of a certain generation namely mine
they're also a surprising representation
of economic inflation to put on my angry
old man hat for a second when I was a
youngin these were 10p and then around
2005 prices started to gradually creep
up before we knew it prices were as high
as 30p for alfredo these outrageous
prices actually led to public outcry so
much so that they back down and I think
nowadays they're around 25 people the
bank of England says that it should have
been around 17 or 18p by now whereas we
are getting charged 25 so cadburys give
us some cheap photos again economic run
is now over you can also get Fresnos in
a caramel flavor the last thing to add
to the chocolate bars is that you can
get pretty much all of them in the form
of these share bags they basically just
condense them into bite-sized pieces and
put them in a bag that you can open and
reseal next up we have dairy milk bites
there are two flavors that we have right
now Hazelnut and almond they look pretty
similar to the silk of these flavors so
I imagine these are just smaller
bite-sized versions next up lickables
why have they done this thoughts on this
this is clearly for small children
somebody want to help me I have no idea
how to open this this feels like one of
those uh puzzles
oh
the lower half of it was the chocolate
and the rest of it had this toy now to
the chocolate there's a QR code because
most children have phones that they can
scan this with oh looks like goopy
Cadbury chocolate with chunks of Oreo
and you just gotta
lick it
this is this weird Cadbury okay next up
we have Cadbury chocolate bakes chalk
filled cookies in case you didn't think
this contained chocolate they reminded
you eight times in The Branding the
packaging and the design feels a lot
more premium okay feel like there's a
good value for money here because it was
filled to the literal brim now we're
going to go to this side we have Oreo
dipped in Cadbury damn I'm really
enjoying this whole Oreo Cadbury
marriage over here now we have an Oreo
biscuit coated in Cadbury chocolate the
Oreo biscuits are kind of overpowering
so it's all right next up we have this
tin can of Rich dry fruits again in the
Cadbury celebrations line in India
common gifting cultures to give a box of
dry fruits and nuts and so Cadbury is
adapted really well to that okay so the
next thing is something very different
this is actually born Vita or Cadbury
bone Vita and this is a drinking
chocolate we drink a lot of milk here in
India and as kids everybody is addicted
to one of many different drinking
chocolates horlicks comp plan I'm a Milo
guy myself there was boost and then
obviously born Vita I think most people
were not born Vita people this is
Cadbury's range of
choco melts and it's a small dish of
chocolate that's used for baking and
finally the last three packets are
toffees that Cadbury sells in bulk this
one is five star bites it's similar to
the dairy milk minis from Indian fans of
five star out there comment and let me
know whether you're more of a rummy's
guy or a Suresh guy these are packs of
toffees eclairs to be specific this one
is chocolate flavored and this one is
coffee flavor another quirky thing about
India is sometimes when you go to the
local stores and you pay in cash and
they have to give you change but they
don't have any they'll just give you one
of these chocolates and you can't really
argue it you just grab it and go I think
it's very cute actually it's a very
endearing thing about India but remember
if you're gonna take a chocolate from a
store screw all this take Melody Melody
is the best chocolate all right in the
UK Capri's offers a lot of seasonal
products now we're recording this
episode in late October so unfortunately
we can't get some of the most famous
ones what I'm of course referring to
here are Cadbury Creme eggs and Cadbury
Mini Eggs in the UK these are only
available in the run-up to the Eastern
holidays but while they are available
they're wildly popular although I will
say I don't like cream eggs I take stick
for this I think they're gross the
fondant in the middle is grim you have
to kind of like tongue it out it's just
really bizarre many eggs however are
delicious I don't know what they're
putting in the shells of those things
but God they're amazing well we can't
get the Easter exclusives right now what
we do have are Halloween and Christmas
options for Halloween I was able to find
these goo heads I think these are kind
of a Halloween version of cream eggs so
I'm going to crack One open and see that
does look exactly the same as a Cream
Egg even down to the patterning that's
kind of printed on the egg I mean yeah
that's pretty much just a Cream Egg
I just don't like them then for
Christmas exclusives I found these
Cadbury puds these are dairy milk
chocolate balls with a truffle Center
hazelnut pieces and rice crisps they
sound pretty good we also found Cadbury
Mini snowballs which are milk chocolate
and a crisp sugar shell they might hurt
a little bit more than a normal snowball
fight if you have one of these thrown at
your head and of course you can get a
Dairy Milk Advent calendar for Christmas
it looks like some kind of mud monster
moving away from seasonal items we have
Cadbury eclairs Cadbury eclairs are
quite tough pieces of toffee with some
chocolate in the center they're a pretty
good jaw workout but I do quite like
these and another iconic Cadbury item is
buttons these are bags of discs of dairy
milk chocolate real classic these have
been around for years from there we're
moving on to Cadbury's biscuit options
possibly the most iconic of which are
fingers these are thin sticks of sweet
biscuit covered in dairy milk chocolate
they're very tasty they're pretty
Moorish and they come in these kind of
iconic sleeve tray things
I know with Joe we have a caffeine meter
but if I had a sugar meter
oh we're blasting off right now well we
also have some other flavor options
including mint orange bornville dark and
finally white roundies are circular
layered wafer biscuits covered in dairy
milk chocolate if you're a fan of Wafers
you can also get time out wafer bars
again it's Chocolate Wafers layered and
surrounded by chocolate but this time in
more of a bar form than a circular
Biscuit the next Cadbury biscuits option
is animals Fredo has hopped into the
jungle to join his friends he's a little
animal-shaped biscuits which on one side
are covered with chocolate I don't think
I've eaten one of these as an adult but
they were an excellent lunchbox Edition
when I was a little kid I'd also be
remiss not to talk about mini rolls
these are an iconic British snack what
it is is like a chocolate sponge with
this kind of cream swirl in the middle
surrounded by milk chocolate I'm not
sure why the mini roll is currently
saying I'm rich and famous but good for
the mini roll these are great finally
Cadbury's offers some baked options
which you might find in the bakery
section of your local supermarket these
can include things like donuts and
muffins but the ones I was able to find
today were Flapjack bites in the UK when
we say Flapjacks we don't mean pancakes
which I think Americans can say
sometimes Flapjacks over here are kind
of like oats held together with honey
golden syrup and some other stuff and
these mini cookies
here's everything in above dairy milk
chocolate in the UK here's everything
you'll find in a bar of dairy milk
chocolate here in India so the list of
ingredients is pretty much the same in
the UK and in India but the UK uses palm
and sheer fats which is not specifically
listed here in India India goes into a
little bit more detail on the flavorings
used in the chocolate listing natural
vanillin as well as artificial ethyl
vanilla as the name suggests this is the
main component of vanilla bean extract
some kind of vanilla is likely present
in the UK chocolate it's just contained
within the flavorings on the list but
how much chocolate are you actually
getting in your chocolate the food
safety and standards authority of India
has some minimum requirements for what
milk chocolate should contain the rules
are 25 total fat 2 milk fat 2.5 cocoa
solids and 10.5 percent milk solids we
have equivalent rules here in the UK the
cocoa and chocolate products regulations
of 2003 set the minimums for milk
chocolate at 25 total fat 5 milk fat 20
dry cocoa solids 2.5 dry non-fat cocoa
solids and 20 dry milk solids Cadbury in
the UK says its chocolate contains 23
milk solids and meets the EU minimum of
20 for Cocoa salads India's Cadbury
packaging says it contains over 22 milk
solids so thank you Cadbury for not
being chindi it is interesting that
Indian rules do not have a minimum for
dry fat free cocoa solids in milk
chocolate the dark chocolates however
have a minimum and it's 14 dry cocoa
solids tends to refer to cocoa powder
which is one of the purest forms of
cocoa having more cocoa solids therefore
gives the end product a stronger
chocolate taste
100 grams of dairy milk in the UK
contains the following 100 grams of
dairy milk in India contains the
calories are actually identical the
least healthy bar in the UK is the big
taste toffee whole nut bar one of these
contains 560 calories per 100 grams a
slight increase on Dairy Milk but what
is the least healthy chocolate bar here
in India
it's the dairy milk silk hazelnut 100
grams of this contains 571 calories
which is more than any bar in the UK I
guess it's a win I'm counting it as a
win from calorie count to portion size
we want to find out all the differences
between Lays chips in the U.S and in
India this is food Wars
here are all the lace chips you will
find in India that you won't find in the
US and here are all the lace chips in
the US you can't find in India oh my
good God yeah
to begin things I'm gonna go with the
one I hate the most Spanish tomato Tango
yeah I've just never really like this
flavor it's just too heavy on the Tomato
side
no oh man that aftertaste is horrible I
have nothing nice to say about this
flavor also just to note our standard
lace chips come in the ridge style we do
also sell the flat style but that's more
of a special variety of lace next it's
West Indies hot and sweet chili formally
Caribbean hot and sweet chili
that's what I'm talking about
get out of here I know
for the Maharaja of Indian leaves magic
Masala if you haven't heard of this you
must be living under a rock because this
is the little emperor of chips commonly
known as blue leaves
look at this
oh my God
it's already so spicy the reason this
chip has become so popular in India is
because they have actually managed to
capture the Masala of India so well and
Masala if you're wondering is like
ground up spices that are added to every
single dish we eat here this is truly
magic I want to know what they're like
Joe got himself some
oh man and the chip bags in India are
like much harder to open oh man you guys
gotta walked up tight
is it gonna rip okay yeah
oh yeah
damn you're good
not too spicy great flavor we have so
many flavors I couldn't get them all for
the shoot I mean I'll just start right
here
barbecue this is like the classic chip I
think this is more popular than the
classic to be honest the US has I would
say at least 10 different variations of
barbecue possibly more so I have just
like standard barbecue is pretty bold
move by lays salt and vinegar
love it so much
chip top chip right here close all
mirror cheddar and sour cream
another favorite oh man
it seems like
lime flavored chips would be weird or
citrusy chips but
it's so good and these are like really
limey all the super fans watching know I
do not like pickles
no let's kick it up a notch blaming hot
dill pickle and the flaming hot that
font that implies that's like flaming
hot Cheetos right
um better still not that good last in
this uh group is a chili lemon
yeah
these are coming home with me other
flavors in this category that I couldn't
get the time of filming cheddar jalapeno
and Sweet Southern heat barbecue I was
totally able to buy them online I get a
thing in the mail two days ago saying
the post office is holding them Ransom
and wants five more dollars for postage
for me to pick it up not happening I
will not be intimidated by the United
States Post Office and keep the chips
all right also what I couldn't get at
the time of filming was honey barbecue
Chesapeake Bay crab spice Adobes which
is a different spicy chip which is
actually very good I was bummed that
couldn't get those and the Doritos Cool
Ranch lays unfortunately
let's now talk about two exclusive
flavors that are in both countries but
slightly different we have uh the
sizzling hot lays and the American style
cream and onion it was previously known
as American sour cream and onion
it's great no fuss one of my favorite
flavors it's been there for like over
two decades I feel in India and there's
a reason for that ours is just regular
sour cream and onion I also got America
style sour cream and onion from India
and then one after the other
the flavor on these are much stronger
and even says now with more this is more
flavor I gotta say I like these India
ones better up next we have sizzling hot
this is the flavor I've actually never
had I'm very excited to see how it
Stacks compared to Magic Masala which is
already pretty spicy whoa
yo look at this chip it's literally red
oh
[Music]
nice it's not as much a direct heat as
the magic Masala hey it's a nice flavor
in the US we have flaming hot Flavor now
let me explain this is flaming hot
kettle chips couldn't get the regular
flaming hot we'll get in the kettle
chips later it's like regular spice as a
heat Tube without being too specific I
think they use these red chilies right
here it packs a nice punch without being
too overwhelming with the flavor like
the perfect amount of heat without
getting too overwhelming okay so we
don't only have Rich style chips we also
have some flat ones in fact they're
called wafer style which I think is
pretty much your classic style of lace
the first flavor is salt with pepper not
salt and pepper don't you dare say that
it's very nice I should buy this more
often I've never tried this before very
good job okay on to the next wafer style
chip we have sun-dried chili
I love sun dried anything beam that Sun
Ray on to any vegetable I will eat it
oh
this is really good they smashed through
this one
got a prop okay well oh it's really yum
and one of the most beautiful sights
you'll see in India is people Sun drying
their own chilies on their roofs porches
wherever biryanis curries they all use
sun dried chili and this chips packet
really has nailed this flavor
maybe my favorite kettle cooked we
already saw the Flamin Hot kettle cooked
these are thicker chip they transport a
lot better obviously and has made broken
a potato taste to it potato snaps like
I love kettle chips sea salt Cracked
Pepper
these are so good
yeah like
sea salt and vinegar this ain't your
pond Salt this ain't your Lake salt this
certainly is not your Fjord salt
why is salt and vinegar so good
attention everyone my favorite Kettle
chip is about to be eaten by me the
jalapeno kettle chips I'm not going to
talk about Miss Vicky's because this
isn't a Miss Vicki's video and I hate to
say it these might be better
but got the jalapeno flavor in there
it's not too spicy so you can really
Chow Down on this moving on
unfortunately to something that I kind
of can't stand are
baked you get them an original and you
get them a barbecue
like eating cardboard Blaze has
something called the better for you
Series so we have these and then lightly
sell the barbecue lightly salted wavy I
mean I want the salt but like how much
this is what paper tastes like we got
simply sea salt thick cut
and you can also get the simply barbecue
thick cut you have something called
layers which are these guys bite-sized
layers crispy layers tasty layers you
get them in three cheese sour cream and
onion I've never seen this before my
entire life oh the best thanks
oh these are these are really bad these
are terrible it was a real chemically
tasting oh my God these tastes like they
were poisoned I know for the next range
of exclusive chips we have lays Max
that's Max with two x's why the two x's
that's the like thing it's more better I
have not seen or tasted these before
starting with Macho chili flavor it is
kinda rich but I would say it's more
very
I wouldn't say it's super spicy I kind
of like that this one doesn't leave that
burning sensation in your throat it's
really nice
yeah I don't know about The Branding but
I really like this flavor next flavor
peppery cheddar
whoa all sorts of stuff happening here
there's like some mint to it oh you know
what this tastes like this tastes like
Malai Tikka like chicken Malai Tikka
dipped in pudina Chutney this is very
uni our next flavor is
sizzling barbecue oh the reason this is
called lace Max it's because it has Max
crunch Max flavor and Max taste and I
can wholeheartedly say both of these
have delivered
foreign
more fun chip Styles I think we can call
these the India style but we also call
them the wavy style they are wavy hence
the name and you get them an original
reduced fat honey barbecue Ranch you
also get them in salt and pepper lightly
salted fat low fat if I didn't say that
already like the waves are like wider
you guys have like really like condensed
waves Blaze apparently went in the
answer the age-old question how can we
copy something popular and make it much
much worse and stacks were invented you
guys know what Pringles are right of
course you do well
hear that we'll put them in a tube they
won't break as easily right holy
look at us
[Music]
so what was the point of putting in this
tube I hate this so much but to really
prove my point yo dog look what I got by
the way paper two excellent idea
Dave Pringle whatever your name is
final set of exclusives The Gourmet
collection I have had a lot of gourmet
food in my life and I've very rarely
been actually impressed with the food
vontos cheese and paprika
vintage cheese and paprika
if I taste this chip without any of the
fancy packaging I don't think Gourmet is
the first word that would come to my
head Thai Sweet Chili Gourmet
this literally tastes like the West
Indies hot in Chile but on a flat chip
so Gourmet is just packaging that's what
we've learned from this experiment with
these two chips
skippable in addition to that we also
have lays poppables poppables coming sea
salt and vinegar C oh Julius Pringle
that was his name not Dave they also
have poppable sea salt and vinegar
poppable sea salt poppable white cheddar
and poppable honey barbecue okay I don't
want to eat all these what's the what's
the cereal that looks like this is it
Chex
if you got these on accident eat them
but I wouldn't I wouldn't reach for
these over regular potato chips
it's come in five sizes it is 30 grams
50 grams 73 grams 104 grams and 174
grams the big boy the party pack I feel
like I could eat this whole thing on my
own to be honest in the US our lace
chips come in six variety of sizes all
the way down here get the 28 gram bag
which comes in the multi-pack next up
74.4 Gram bag in the middle here there's
also an elusive 78 gram bag look I saw
it on target.com and walmart.com it
exists it just wasn't available anywhere
in Southern California I looked okay one
step up we have what I think is the
classic
Grocery Store bag
226 gram aka the eight ounce bag you've
seen it a million times this is the one
right next to that one is the family
size bag which I also couldn't get a
hold of
297.6 gram bag I couldn't find it
because the American family is dead but
what is Alive and Well is of course our
biggest size the party size
368 grams for all you familyless
Partiers lays has you covered that means
the biggest bag in the US is this much
larger than the biggest bag in India but
wait there's more or less depending on
the packet that you get because
according to Amazon the weights of these
different packets might vary so they're
given a weight range the biggest weight
difference is in our largest pack of 174
to 190 grams which is a difference of 16
grams so let's see how much we get in
one package
175 grams one gram extra from what is
advertised which is I'll take it so let
me show you what 16 grams of chips looks
like so you can see what you're
potentially missing out on it doesn't
seem like a lot but I think that's quite
a substantial amount of chips you're
missing out on to be fair they they did
write 174 grams only on the pack in the
US our flavor bags weigh less than the
original flavor bag take this barbecue
flavored lace bag it weighs 7.75 ounces
or seven and three-fourths ounces Yulie
can we get in there you see that thank
you compared to the eight ounce you get
with the original bag okay same price
less product now Harry did research on
that episode so take it away Harry
what no do your own research according
to Harry's research from the last latest
episode back in 2014 PepsiCo claimed the
reason that there is a slightly higher
price per ounce for flavor chips is the
added seasoning so then
lays can you explain to me why this
lightly salted bag gives you fewer chips
in the original bag that's more money
but less salt a lays check it out the
lightly salted so less salted than this
also seven and three-fourths while we're
exposing potential lays lies this 28
gram bag in the U.S supposedly contains
15 chips according to Lay's website
let's see how accurate this is and I'm
going to go on all the tips in this 30
gram packet to see how many we have
ha
I mean it doesn't contain one whole chip
one
12.
13. I mean if we're doing it by chip
related piles 6 12 8 moving close to 18
chips per bag huh all right I'll concede
cool so that's 24 chips I would say
realistically this is like 20 chips that
have been broken into many other pieces
but let's be real they could have fit a
lot more chips into this packet and lace
is notorious for filling it with air
it's actually nitrogen gas which helps
preserve the chips and also acts as a
cushion to stop them from getting
smashed in transit I mean
what would it have been like without the
cushion this whole bag would have been
dust apparently but what is the air to
chip ratio you ask let's find out in a
new segment I like to call the art
chipmedies principle
can I just say this is one of the
weirdest things I've done in my life a
generous 55 mL of chips in this packet
now let's measure how much the packet
itself can hold in volume
oh this smells so bad
900 mL that's
845 mL of chips that we could have had
lace I feel cheated which I think to
make it more accurate let's do four and
then we'll fill this guy up and then
we'll divide by four and that would give
us the average of those does that make
sense dust
all right oh man all right can I please
have the scientific chip crunching
nunchucks throw them
whoa look out chips pow wow how
2.75 fluid ounces per bag now that's
science you can use
so now we're going to fill this with
water cool the whole thing's 20. I'm
expect 2.75
17.25 units or whatever cubic fluid
ounces even more interesting ad
information because of India's very
geography the amount of air that's
backed into these packets is different
for different altitudes for example in
cities of higher altitude like lay in
the Himalayas there is the risk of these
packets exploding
due to the low atmospheric pressure and
so when they're sent there they're sent
with no air at all inside of them and so
they run the risk of being crushed in
transport so they have to be taken as
delicately as a crate of eggs
[Music]
but what about price
this is our largest chips packet the 174
grams and on swiggy and Amazon this
sells for about 78 rupees which is about
a dollar right now and that equals
foreign
about
0.005 dollars and yes I did all of that
math and conversion in my head here in
the us if we break it down starting with
this big bag the 226.8 gram AKA eight
ounce bag it's 3.99 at Target or
316.58 rupees yes it's a bigger bag I
know so breaking it down per gram we
found that in the US the cost is at 260
increase compared to India while we do
enjoy at least chips we also have a
giant chip culture here in uh India in
fact these are called hot chips and they
sold all across India at stalls called
Hot Chip stores where basically they
have a giant frying pan and they cut the
potato in front of you to these thin
slices and fry it and give it to you
nice hot hot fresh fresh and so for 174
grams which is the same as this you're
paying rupees 45 for a lot fresher chips
so as you can see lasers competing
against a giant chip Market here in
India and doing pretty well I would say
[Music]
now for the burning question are there
any questionable ingredients that are in
your lace chips that you need to watch
out for fret not because Joe and I have
found them out for you as far as the
basic salted version goes you're totally
fine both in India and the US they're
made of potatoes vegetable oil salt
warning warning alert here India some of
our flavors have an ingredient called
potassium chloride in regular doses this
is completely safe and it's a low sodium
alternative to Salt however it's also
one of the three ingredients used in the
three drug cocktail per Lethal
Injections too much potassium chloride
will cause irregular heartbeats and boom
your heart will stop so if you've been
thinking of doing a lace mukbang be
careful we don't have any of that in the
US lace but we do have food coloring
caramel color in our barbecue
and honey barbecue chips certain types
of caramel color can contain a byproduct
called four dash me uppercase i studies
found that it caused cancer in rats and
mice leading campaigns in support of
banning it from foods give me that
dancing rat
all right the FDA was like nah it's fine
humans don't come close to the level of
exposure that caused that rat tumors but
that didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list of
chemicals quote known to the states of
California to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity end quote another
ingredient found in several varieties of
relationships here in India is disodium
glutamate AKA flavor enhancer 69 no not
69.
flavor enhances 627 but basically it's
used alongside MSG to enhance the flavor
of the chips both the Food and Drug
Administration or the FDA in the United
States and the European Food Safety
Authority or the efsa consider disodium
glutamate safe but it's not recommended
for babies children pregnant women and
lactating mothers and also should be
avoided by asthmatics or people
suffering from gout MSC if you're
wondering is the commonly misunderstood
ingredient known as monosodium glutamate
which is added to a lot of Asian Cuisine
and gives it that Umami flavor in 2019
lays suited bunch of Indian Farmers for
growing a certain variety of potatoes
fc5 variety saying it has a patent on
that variety this type of potato is
ideal for snack chips as it has a lower
moisture content but strike one of the
little guy Farmer's rights activists
petition the protection of the plant
varieties and Farmers rights Authority
and it agreed PepsiCo lays cannot claim
a patent over a seed variety it was
revoked immediately and the Indian
potato farmers are now flush with low
moisture potato money let's go
[Music]
so which country has the unhealthiest
chips let's compare the classics first a
28 gram bag of classic lays in the U.S
contains 160 calories 10 grams of total
fat 1.5 grams of saturated fat 15 grams
of carbs and 170 milligrams of sodium
okay so our least nutrition is put 100
grams so I did a little bit of math to
compare it to the US 28 grams actually
during the mat so if the math is wrong
blame okay so we have 154.8 calories
total fat 9.8 grams of which saturates
are 3.7 grams carbs are 14.7 grams and
sodium
142.8 milligrams wow that was pretty
close actually we're under the U.S in
every metric except for saturated fats
where we are over 164 and I think that's
because we use parmoline oil to fry our
chips and it's very high in saturated
fats unlike the U.S vegetable oil what
about the least healthiest chip in each
country over here there are a lot of
them that are tied to 160 calories per
28 gram bag show list but we did find
that the 160 calorie chips with the
highest fat content are these no the
challenge sour cream I love these guys
making them the least healthy if I did
have a bag that small it would contain
all of this
and here in India our highest calorific
chip is classic salted how lame how is
this the most calorific chip we sell
here layers if I had to run an extra
mile it wouldn't be for classic salted
so you know what the next most calorific
chip is
magic Masala baby blue lace we had to
end with this one super calorific I
don't know why I'm proud of that but uh
good great to know that this is and
forever will be the Maharaja of lays
from calorie count to portion says we
want to find out all the differences
between Taco Bell in India and the US
this is food Wars
here in India our typical tacos come in
orders of one two in a two taco meal
with fries and a drink three Taco Trio
combo which comes with nachos and a
drink or on weekends they have a special
offer where you can get eight tacos in
their weekend taco party
eight weekend party pack taco
eat taco we can party pack have a party
with your friends only there are eight
of them and they all are okay with
having just one taco in the U.S our
standard Taco Bell tacos come in orders
of one three with a drink and the 12
Taco Box 12 tacos one box item here in
India our classic burrito is six and a
half centimeters or six and a half
inches our U.S burrito is five inches
across in terms of good it's the first
time I've measured the growth of
anything promise seven inches also about
five inches and that's what matters most
okay now to measure the weight of our
classic burrito damn this is a big boy
291 grams
185 grams our classic quesadilla is just
shy of 11 inches 10 inches and as for
weight
and it weighs 174 grams 202 grams add an
Indian Taco Bell the largest item we
have on menu is the aforementioned
weekend a taco party picnic puffing what
the what is this thing eight Taco
weekend party pack and it's always a
party
so the vegetarian version is 499 rupees
and the non-resistant version is 599
rupees in the US our biggest menu item
is a supreme variety taco party pack it
is 12. supreme tacos and it runs 21.99
or
1751.65 Indian rupee
here's everything you'll find at a Taco
Bell in India that you will not find in
the US and here is everything at a U.S
Taco Bell you can't find in India let's
Taco about it here in India all of the
tacos have a vegetarian option it's
because even though India is a primarily
non-vegetarian country we have a huge
population of vegetarians or people who
have different preferences of what kind
of meat they like to eat and so it's
great for most of these fast food chains
to have a lot of veg options all of them
have the option of either pinto beans
fajita veggies or Mexican paneer and
they're also in increasing order of
spice the cheesy double decker Taco
honestly I actually really like the
stuff I know it's sacred for some people
to eat a softer and harsher Taco
together but when you parcel this stuff
and get it delivered to you both the
tacos become soft shrimp
William all right the next attack I'm
going to eat is a crunchy taco plain and
simple it's got pinto beans in it it's
unfair to like this on a crunchy taco
after you've ordered it from a
restaurant that's far away because look
at this it becomes soggy already so I'm
gonna be gentle on my criticism of this
but you use soft shell tacos are getting
it huh
just do some decent crunch to it here in
India pinto beans are what we call rajma
and they're a staple in lava rajma so
it's a perfect match to put them in a
taco next up another crunchy taco this
one is the Mexican paneer now paneer if
you're unaware is cottage cheese we make
it all over here in India we basically
take curdle milk add some sort of fruit
or vegetable acid to it like lemon juice
and you get cottage cheese which is
paneer I'm curious to know what makes
this Mexican
paneer is one of the most popular things
you'll find in India at any restaurant
this paneer tastes chalky like most
processed paneer that you'd store in a
freezer wood if you prefer your paneer
chunky you might enjoy this tea not so
much now on to the soft shell tacos uh
this one is Mexican paneer the same
thing I just had
this Mexican company is a little bit
more spicy my favorite thing about tacos
is that not every bite is uniform so you
get a lot of different textures and
flavors in each bite you take and I
guess that's proving its point over here
okay so the next one we're gonna try is
a soft taco with fajita veggies inside
I'm opting out of the fajita veggies as
a filling in general and finally we have
our last veggie option which is a veggie
Fiesta which has tater tots
win that's a win if I was going to Taco
Bell I had to order a veggie Taco for
some reason my option would be a crunchy
pinto bean taco and now for our
non-esitating tacos please note that all
of the meat in our tacos is chicken and
not beef this is because we have a huge
percentage of Hindus here in India and
they do not eat beef this makes all of
our non-veg tacos exclusives because yes
in the US you can substitute your beef
for chicken but it's not on the official
menu all right it's a modification which
means these are more exclusives to India
okay so you have two options of filling
either Mexican chicken or grilled
chicken we're starting off with a
grilled chicken crunchy taco which has
severely disintegrated not bad this is
also kind of the test of Taco Bell's uh
structural Integrity pretty good
[Music]
that's a win for me what else do you
want Taco Bell this Taco though has seen
better times
it kind of reminds me of like a rajma
chawl when you're chewing on the Raj
myself that's how soft the chicken is
there are a lot of comparisons you can
make with Mexican and Indian food we
have something exactly like this in
India it's called chapati and it's made
out of wheat the tortillas in Mexico are
typically made with corn the one in Taco
Bell is made out of maida which is
all-purpose flour I can't speak for
Mexican Cuisine but there's definitely a
lot of Indian flavors in this
this is actually a soft grilled chicken
taco and I can wholeheartedly say worse
to the bunch don't get this one a cheese
double decker Taco with grilled chicken
again come on man I wanted the Mexican
one but the hard shell taco is
disintegrating into a soft shell tacos
there's nothing special Chicken Fiesta
taco oh my God I didn't expect that at
all
first been chewing for so long I'm so
tired oh damn the aftertaste of this is
really good this is not a nice spice to
it now we have a very special Taco as
you can see this one is still wrapped
because I've never seen this in my life
it's called a naked chicken taco pause
for a moment what do you think that
means oh my God ladies and gentlemen
the naked chicken taco
[Music]
genuinely feels like I just undressed
food so there's no chicken filling
inside it because the chicken is the
Taco that's right that's how far we've
come as the human race we have taken
this bird and turned it into a freaking
pancake and folded it over cheese your
scientists were too busy trying to
figure out whether they could do it they
didn't stop to think whether they should
do it
nice
I think that might be one of the worst
things I've had on this show oh God oh
God
I'm gonna be honest it actually looks
pretty good to me that reminds me of the
KFC double down which I did actually
enjoy I try it starting off soft taco
and soft taco supreme which is beef
flimsiest thing in the world
this stuff is all this stuff is sweating
already
so I don't know how many vegetarians are
watching now but look at what you're
missing I think I just created a few
vegetarians I mean I like how they taste
but I mean Taco Bell's got so much fun
stuff on the menu what are you doing
eating regular tacos like get out of
here crunchy taco which we saw earlier
fantastic even a little more stuff in it
beef Supreme Taco it really loaded up
with the veggies India India India look
at me this is my favorite thing in the
Taco Bell menu I sing its phrases at
every Taco Bell food Wars it is the
nacho cheese Doritos Locos Tacos some
genius somewhere connected Taco Bell and
Doritos to make a hard shell taco that
is in fact a Doritos ciao
mmm comes in standard and of course
Supreme
this is I've been looking forward to
this all day it's burrito time baby I've
got a Mexican paneer version here as
well as a pinto beans version I think
I'll go with the pinto beans one by the
way this tray is all the vegetarian
burritos and this is the non-regetarian
tray happy baby India has a lot of roll
culture we have Gotti rules we have
kolkataros we also have shavarmas which
we're a huge fan of
most Indians this basically will feel
like you took rajma rice and you shove
it inside a maida roti I think I'd go
with the taco over this next up we have
tikka masala but I found this so
recently it was actually invented by the
British so clearly inspired by India but
invented by them another thing that the
British took from us that we haven't
been paid back for
we have a flavor here which is called
achary and it's basically like a pickle
this is more acharya than chicken tikka
masala also I would be lying if I didn't
admit that Taco Bell it's all it's
already doing its thing to my digestive
system Taco Bell is notorious for making
you go to the bathroom zoom in to my
stomach right now and just listen to
this the noises and let's get a
translation
and now for Sriracha wedge burrito is
now running the risk of offending three
different cultures I don't normally eat
a burrito by ripping it in half actually
that sounds awesome we should do that
more often like a double-handed don't
clip that
you can skip it we have the seven layer
burrito
this one tastes like all of these put
together and we have one last veg wrap
ah guys I can't do this it's the same
thing this is tater tots that same
filling I bow down and defeat Taco Bell
you have vanquished me moving on to the
non vegetarian burritos and we're hoping
some of these are a little more distinct
from the others all right we have a
classic Mexican chicken burrito
this is so bad this is damn bad let's
just say I'm glad you didn't call
yourself burrito bowl next up tikka
masala but now in non-veg
[Music]
this is actually quite good this one
doesn't taste as dry as the other ones
I've had and of course we have the seven
layer non-vegetarian burrito instead of
paneer we have grilled chicken let's
just do the slab test again
you could really hurt somebody with this
seven layer one okay we have one last
burrito which is why what is this this
is not why have you done this this
burrito looks like the the love child of
all other burritos over here these
burritos are definitely related and this
is the product of incest
honestly out of all of these I'd prefer
to finish this one because it's just
smaller the pain will end faster
burritos might not be visually the most
exciting part of the video but please
don't leave maybe just open some clips
of Family Guy next to it so you can
watch that and this like you're on Tick
Tock the double steak grilled cheese
burrito and the spicy double steak
grilled cheese burrito and right it's
grilled cheese because they like Grill
it shut which is genius idea yeah look
at that there's jalapenos on it oh
that's fantastic that's a really great
idea
oh yeah just rules a beefy quesarito
when these things cool off though this
is a lot of cheese in there oh and it
has a rice in it well burritos have rice
I don't know I'm so surprised by that
rice and a burrito same thing but with
black beans I mean it's already kind of
kind of like dripping out there already
grilled number one beans and cheese in
there you see that and the red is uh
those like chips they put those crispy
chips in there five layer burrito it
used to be seven layer took out two
layers and added a beefy one for some
weird reason I assure you there's five
layers in beef inside I'm not doing that
I'm not some weird fetish that on the
internet that I'm not aware of slapping
faces with burritos burrito supreme look
it's so much different from the last
thing we were just looking at but like
that one's just like
CK chipotle chicken
yeah Chipotle Nails legit an extra one
if anyone wants it go ahead and comment
below and I'll mail it to you beefy
melts beef and melted cheese I can't
believe it together at last
I mean it tastes like all the other ones
I feel like we could pair this menu down
a little bit last and not least cheesy
bean and rice now for India's
Specialties I am excited for the
diversity that's all I'll say very
representative of our country let's
start off with the chalupa The Humble
chalupa
it's nice if you guys are at home
wondering what the difference between a
normal taco and a chalupa is you should
Google it what is this I mean education
show I'm sure to eat man for my Indian
present it's kind of the difference
between a chapati and like a batura they
actually fry it a little bit
but that was a very horrible place to
bite because I only got chicken I have a
soft spot for the chalupa and it gets my
approval we have the wet star wrap voila
so inventive let's take a burrito but
make it flat oh wow don't make me eat
this Insider please
[Music]
oh I'm coming from a country where we're
used to eating something like this a
chapati with a sabzi on the side which
is like a curry which has vegetables and
fresh paneer and maybe some chicken so
to eat something like this just feels
not even supper it just feels wrong I'm
actually curious to know if any Mexicans
watching this video okay let me know in
the comments whether you feel like Taco
Bell has done Justice to representing
your cuisine in any way next up we have
a Kickstart count of Applause I'm just
gonna keep this UFO of man's worst
accomplishment over here quesadilla
fajita veg very thin I'm curious to know
how they fit a lot of fajita veggies
into it
they haven't how do people do this my
God I just realized Joe is insane how
have you eaten so much Taco Bell Joe
yeah I'm insane I lost my mind somewhere
during the Japan season oh well and it's
strange because I'm still an intern
we're doing at high schoolers now oh
yeah it looks really good
um if it was abstract art in a museum
about 20 meters away from your eyeballs
but when you come close and then you're
faced with the proposition of eating it
[Music]
I can feel my body rejecting this
otherwise it's fine I mean it's it's
just very average this is a normal rice
bowl
we have the same thing another Ice Bowl
but this time it's got some grilled
chicken in there
that was really good this feels like the
safest bet I don't know when anything is
still so let's go through together the
first thing this is uh either a black
bean chalupa or a dirty diaper I can't
tell because it's thick and wrinkly and
just dripping with black goo don't want
that oh it's this uh yeah I mean every
time these Doritos shall show up I'm
just happy Dorito Cheesy Gordita Crunch
nacho cheese they put every word in that
oh it's that thing but not nachos I mean
once you have the Dorito shell version
like to go back is like no way no way
I've touched the sky I can stay on the
ground no longer and then we have two
Crunchwrap Supreme options black bean
Crunchwrap Supreme and then the regular
Crunchwrap Supreme is of course filled
with beef okay it's time now for India's
sides menu starting off with Mexican
corn salad
you don't need to add too much sauce to
it I feel like this could have been a
lot simpler and people would appreciate
it more next up we have loaded fries and
loaded uh nachos so typically Taco Bell
does not serve loaded nachos and loaded
fries here in India but we found a
restaurant that was kind enough to send
it to us anyways I will say this is
probably my favorite thing about Taco
Bell in India the loaded nachos are
banging when you get them at the
restaurant
and now we have two bath bags just
kidding chicken nachos they had chicken
tacos and now there are chicken nachos
and our second doggy bag has whoa that
was alarming because what I saw was this
I did not expect this to come out of
that bag crispy chicken slips sides baby
we got them cheesy Fiesta potatoes
there's better things to be had on the
menu if I do like those black beans
black beans and rice and you can get a
guacamole side now here are some items
that are available both in India and the
us but are still very different for
example this is India's quesadilla
grilled cheese quesadilla but as you can
see it's filled with a lot of fajita
veggies it's got like this special
creamy sauce and it's topped with a lot
of jalapenos whereas in the U.S it comes
with just cheese how boring is that
correct and this is what it looks like
incredibly boring another big difference
is here in India are nachos are all
seasons so they already have like a
masala or some sort of spice to them our
nacho chips in the US are just regular
tortilla chips with nacho cheese
here in India in our veg options we use
pinto beans or rajma whereas in the U.S
our Bean of choice is the black bean
exclusive U.S sauces hey you know what
that means Source talk it's now time for
India's exclusive sauces we have quite
the wide range we have pool Ranch
because there's a lot of spice in a lot
of these burritos and tacos I imagine if
you're somebody who can't tolerate spice
definitely get a side of this then there
is spicy salsa I tasted it it's really
nice it's got a lot more spiced it but
also the flavor of imli which is
tamarind we use it in a lot of our
dishes especially South Indian dishes
then there's a chocolate sauce which I
imagine is for churros or some sort of
dippable dessert but if you want to dip
your quesadilla into this I'm not gonna
judge next up we have lava sauce which
doesn't really look as much like lava
but it definitely has a kick to it
chicken tikka masala sauce which looks
more like lava down on the end here we
got reduced fat sour cream who doesn't
like chips and sour cream right
could use some fat then moving on we
have a chipotle sauce Ole sauce is very
good
avocado ranch
I love it more of that please they have
a spicy ranch how spicy could it be not
very and finally the red sauce okay it
is finally dessert time I have eaten a
lot of savory food and I'm excited for
the desserts good old churros I am a big
fan of churros they send you one
chocolatey dip
I feel like you can't really go wrong
with Churros if you want to call
yourself a restaurant and next is
something I have never seen before
cinnamon twisties
I could see myself you know 3am in the
night sad vulnerable eating a whole
packet of these so that means it's a
good dessert Taco Bell used to sell
quesadillas filled with chocolate and
they were called choco Diaz but I guess
they've stopped that now Taco Bell is
against puns the only U.S exclusive
dessert we have are these the Cinnabon
Delights Cinnabons I'm pretty sure this
is filled with some sort of like cream
cheese right
I share this cream cheese in this or
whatever they're frosting someone's
gotta eat that definitely can't go to
waste eat it now
right they're fantastic all right it's
time for India's exclusive drinks what
could we do without them nothing out of
choke to death on all that burrito maida
wrap first up uh the soft drinks that we
have we sell seven up and mirinda over
here but actually in Bangalore I've seen
a lot more variety of drinks so I think
it varies from store to store next up
Taco Bell sells juices this one was a
mixed fruit juice but I drank it all and
I can tell you it was pretty good they
also sell a cranberry and apple juice
but the stores that we asked in Mumbai
did not have those available and finally
they sell milkshakes this is mango this
is chocolate cookie crumble the true
test of a milkshake is to test the fruit
one and see if it's still fresh
hey that's pretty good mango milkshake
U.S exclusive drinks there's literally a
million yes really of soft drinks you
can get a Taco Bell you can't get in
India so I just went and got a Diet
Pepsi and of course
Baja Blast after like doing this what
three four times at this point I'm
actually starting to like Baja Blast you
can actually get a whole bunch of soft
drinks at the U.S Taco Bell all of these
I wasn't getting 20 drinks you know so
get yourself a bottle OJ Tropicana also
something you can get are things called
freezes which at one point were frozen
slushy or slurpy like drinks you can get
of course a Mountain Dew Baja Blast and
also get yourself Wild Cherry fruits
that's cough syrup
also you can get coffee both iced and
hot
it's coffee
oh no wait that's soda what is this
ignore that over there
gave us two of these iced coffee that's
flavored like the Cinnabon Delights are
you kidding me I can just feel my life
expectancy just getting closer and
closer just like except
he ain't seen his 80s
but it's worth that's delicious you can
also get those coffees Hot Taco Bell
breakfast baby
I think this is just about everything
once again I can't tell what anything is
it's all just a sea of beige let's find
out together this one just says bacon
thank you for that burrito with bacon
I'm like the Riddler over here just like
Yay figured out question mark question
mark I mean it's a bit unnatural how
yellow that is it's really bright it's a
bit concerning this one's gonna be the
one with steak I assume
who's hungry
stick's a little weird maybe I don't get
the steak one specifically I'll just see
this just a condensation how bad this
food is sweating Breakfast Crunchwrap
Supreme oh there's sausage inside of
this what comes inside like the magic
ticket now I get to work at Taco Bell or
something their sausage is good though
get yourself a hash brown They also have
breakfast salsa with the Taco Bell I
went to did not have any
let's talk about nutrition everybody's
favorite topic that's why you come to
food Wars because you love fast food but
mainly you love nutrition in India a
typical soft shell Mexican chicken taco
will be 185 calories in the US our
standard chicken soft taco is 160
calories so we have fewer calories fat
carbs and sodium but more protein next
up is a chicken quesadilla ours has
268.5 calories and ours is 510 calories
now please note the sodium level on our
quesadilla it's over half the daily
recommended amount that's a salty
quesadilla in India a vegetar app is
239.9 calories closest way after that is
our black bean Crunchwrap Supreme again
double the calorie count get a load of
that sodium
are you looking for the most calorific
item here in India well look no further
than the cinnamon twists each of these
packets will cost you 480.9 calories
here in the US if you're having a hard
time finding calories at the Taco Bell
check out this the double beef grilled
cheese burrito
so Taco Bell in India does not disclose
any other ingredients but I thought it
would be interesting to talk about two
of the ingredients that we have here
that are unique to India number one is
paneer so the problem with the Mexican
paneer that was served to me in this
batch of Taco Bell is that it tasted
like the process paneer you get at
stores it tasted like something that had
been stored in a fridge also because
paneer is so popular here in India every
single fast food restaurant has paneer
options you know when you know how well
it can be done I didn't like the paneer
that much in the burritos and tacos I
had today the next ingredient I want to
talk about is Tikka Masala I thought it
was okay it had a lot of flavor it was
quite spicy but the thing that makes
tikka masala so exciting is that it's
always made from fresh tomatoes and so
you can sort of tell there's a
difference when it's in the sauce form
however I will say it's always a valiant
effort to see these fast food companies
and people who come here from abroad in
general adapt to the Indian palette and
try to make Cuisine that matches ours in
the US we do disclose our ingredients
and here's a few you should be wary of
first is brominated vegetable oil AKA
BVO BVO is an emulsifier found in Citrus
flavored sodas that specifically use
citrus oils and is considered a health
risk when ingested in large amounts in
one case a man who drank two to four
liters of BVO soda per day developed
bromism and experienced symptoms such as
memory loss and extreme muscle fatigue
it can be found in the ingredients of
three of the Cantina menu freezes the
beach Berry freeze the ginger mule
freeze and the party punch freeze the
last one the party punch freeze also
contains yellow number five AKA tired
which is subject to restriction outside
the U.S in places like the EU and India
as it quote may have a diverse effect on
activity and attention in children and
you can find it in several Taco Bell
menu items specifically the Doritos
Locos Taco nacho cheese shells oh no I
had like three of those today and Baja
Blast I just want to starting to like it
I just want to shout out to Jewel and
say I understand what drama you must be
going through after doing so many Taco
Bell episodes you know brave brave man
you